Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 107. Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Und heute, nach tatsächlich zehn Jahren, ich bin erst einmal wieder nach Holland gefahren ins Estec.
Das Estec ist das Europäische Weltraumforschungs- und Technologiezentrum, ESA.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Standorte der ESA quer über Europa verteilt und nicht
nur in Europa, es gibt ja auch den Raumfahrt-Startplatz in Kourou.
Aber hier ist sozusagen der Ort, wo die Satelliten getestet werden,
wo sehr viel Technik auch entwickelt wird, auch Forschung gemacht wird,
alles Mögliche wird hier gemacht.
Und heute wollen wir über ein Projekt sprechen, was gerade so richtig erst gestartet ist,
nämlich das Artemis-Projekt, was eigentlich ein NASA-Projekt ist,
aber bei dem auch die ESA eine Beteiligung hat, nämlich in Form des sogenannten Service Modules.
Um darüber zu sprechen, begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner heute nämlich den
Tobias Lagener. Hallo Tobias. Hallo Tim. Herzlich Willkommen bei Raumzeit.
Ja Tuias, wie lange bist du denn schon hier beim ASTEC?
Ja ich bin hier 2010 angefangen. Ich war zuerst als Ingenieur in der Forschung
und Entwicklung tätig. Antriebsbereich, Aerothermodynamik.
In der Industrie dann?
Ne ne, die finde ich direkt nach der, also ich habe erst, also ich habe in Stuttgart
und in Amerika studiert.
Und danach in Stuttgart dann promoviert. Mein Thema damals war Brennkammerkühlung
für Raumfahrtantriebe.
Also direkt, du hast Weltraumtechnik?
Ja genau, ich habe Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik in Stuttgart studiert.
Das ist eine große Universität für Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik.
Und dann mein Promotionsprojekt, da hatte ich Verbindungen hier zu ESA.
Ich war vorher auch mal zum Praktikum hier, das ist jetzt auch schon 17 Jahre her.
Und gut, dadurch bin ich dann bei der ESA gelandet. Hab dann in Technologie
im Forschungsbereich gearbeitet und dann auch angefangen,
Projekte zu unterstützen im Antriebstechnologiebereich, also Studien,
Auslegungen, Simulationen und nachher halt auch mehr auf Systemebene.
Ich habe dann quasi immer meinen Arbeitsbereich vergrößert, habe dann irgendwann
angefangen, ExoMars zu supporten vom Antriebsbereich.
Das ist ja die Mission der ESA, die damals in Zusammenarbeit mit der russischen
Raumfahrtagentur Roskosmos war, die ja mittlerweile stillgelegt ist.
Aus den bekannten Gründen.
Aus den bekannten Gründen, ja. Und da gab es zwei Missionen.
2016, das ist ein Orbiter am Mars mit einem Landedemonstrator,
da habe ich ein bisschen dran gearbeitet. Und dann halt vor allen Dingen die
Mission, die damals 2018 nach 2020 hieß, wo man den europäischen Rover mit einer
russischen Kapsel auf den Mars landen wollte.
War ich da für die Antriebssysteme verantwortlich oder habe ich das Projekt
unterstützt mit Technologie Know-How.
Ganz schön frustrierend, wenn so eine Mission, an der man jahrelang arbeitet,
dann einfach so mir nichts, dir nichts aus politischen Gründen fällt, oder?
Das stimmt natürlich, wenn man da lange lang gearbeitet hat.
Das ist jetzt, ich habe dann Gott sei Dank vorher, bevor die Mission stattfand,
schon in dieses europäische Service-Modulprojekt gewechselt gehabt.
Allerdings, ich weiß, dass die Leute, das Projektteam von ExoMars,
die hatten schon ihre Koffer gepackt und wollten gerade los nach Baikonur.
Die Launchkampagne wäre im März losgegangen und im Februar ist natürlich der
Ukrainekrieg begonnen.
Gut, danach guckt man dann erstmal
ein bisschen blöd und man weiß nicht so richtig, was man machen soll.
Jetzt ist die Mission umdefiniert, seit der Ministerratskonferenz,
die Exumas Mission, dass es einen reinen europäischen Land ergibt mit amerikanischer Beteiligung.
Und ja, hoffen wir, dass wir dann unseren Rover dann noch auf dem Mars bekommen.
Aber gut, das Thema ist ja jetzt die Europäische Service Modul.
Aber das Thema ist halt auch wirklich auch diese Kooperation NASA und ESA,
die es ja schon immer gab und viele Projekte hatte.
Aber Russland spielte natürlich eine große Rolle, das fällt jetzt komplett weg.
Das bedeutet ja im Prinzip hier auch eine Neuausrichtung in vielerlei Hinsicht.
Na gut, ich meine, auf der Raumstationsebene geht die Kooperation weiter.
Das war auch nie auf Arbeitsebene ein Problem, so wie ich das verstanden habe.
Und auch politisch wurde da nicht so richtig daran gezweifelt,
obwohl es da von russischer Seite, sage ich mal, Kommunikation gab,
die wirklich unter der Gütelinie waren.
Aber es läuft weiter. Ich habe auch, als ich in Houston war,
da waren Russen im Kontrollzentrum, die halt für die ISS zuständig waren,
die waren nicht weg, die waren dann ganz normal und haben weiter gearbeitet.
Es ist ja auch bitter, muss ich sagen. Ich begleite ja die Szene von außen auch
schon öfter und ich kenne einfach keinen Bereich, der so...
Eigentlich mehr globale Friedenspolitik macht als die Raumfahrt.
Weil hier einfach so die internationale Kooperation schon immer,
wie soll ich sagen, der Politik eigentlich weit entrückt und voraus war in gewisser Hälfte.
China ist noch ein schwieriges Thema, aber auch da gibt es ja auch sehr viel
mehr Kooperation, als man es an anderen Stellen teilweise findet.
Ja genau, ich denke mal, die friedliche Nutzung der Raumfahrt ist natürlich ein Bereich,
auf dem man kooperieren kann, weil das ist im Endeffekt eine wissenschaftsgetriebene
Industrie, auf der man natürlich kooperieren kann ohne große politische oder Sicherheitsprobleme.
Aber es gibt halt größere Projekte, auf denen dann auch eine echte Zusammenarbeit stattfinden kann.
Zum Beispiel im Multimillionen-Euro-Bereich natürlich.
Und da kann dann dadurch eine signifikante Kooperation mit Russland oder China oder natürlich den USA,
unser Hauptpartner möchte ich jetzt mal meinen, in der man in den Raum fährt,
durchgeführt werden, die auch auf politischer Ebene etwas Beachtung findet.
Aber wir wollen ja heute eigentlich über Artemis sprechen, über dieses Projekt.
Das ist ja nun auch so ein Projekt, was so lange Zeit etwas holprig vorangekommen ist.
Dahinter steckt ja die Idee, nach vielen, vielen Jahrzehnten der Inaktivität
auf dem Mond endlich mal wieder dort Weltraumfahrt zu betreiben.
Da kommt natürlich auch noch mal so ein neuer Aspekt mit rein für die Raumfahrt,
jenseits der reinen Wissenschaft.
Das ist natürlich jetzt hier auch so die Idee des Mondes als einerseits als
Standort, aber eben vielleicht auch als industrielle Nutzung.
In gewisser Hinsicht steckt ja dann auch noch so ein bisschen im Hintergrund.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch so weltraumrechtlich.
Das soll heute nicht das Thema sein, aber das steht auf jeden Fall alles so
ein bisschen im Raum, dass sich hier einfach komplett neue Fragen stellen.
Aber zunächst einmal geht es ja darum, vor allem aus Perspektive der Amerikaner,
nach der Apollo-Mission hier endlich mal wieder den Fokus auf den Mond zu richten.
Das ist auch schon eine Weile her mit dem Constellation-Programm.
Das war, glaube ich, so der erste Ansatz, der aber nicht so funktioniert.
Ja, also es gab natürlich erstmal das Shuttle,
was halt schon in den 60ern im Endeffekt konzipiert wurde parallel zu Apollo
und was dann halt in den 80ern, glaube ich, in Betrieb genommen wurde.
Und als dann die Entscheidung getroffen wurde, dann keine Shuttle-Flüge mehr
durchzuführen, muss man natürlich irgendwie ein Ersatzprogramm herstellen,
mit dem man größere Raumschiffe in den Weltall außerhalb von dem Leos,
vom Low Earth Orbit, kriegen kann.
Es gibt ja in Amerika auch Industriepolitik. Es ist ja nicht so,
dass die Amerikaner davon frei sind.
Ein Shuttle-Programm war ein sehr großes Programm, das große Industrien beschäftigt
hat, viele Leute in Arbeit gehalten hat und natürlich müsste man da irgendwie
anknüpfen, um auch die Technologien weiter zu nutzen, das Know-How nicht zu
verlieren und so weiter.
Dann gab es halt, ich glaube George Bush.
Junior hat das Programm oder während seiner Präsidentschaft wurde dieses Constellation-Programm
in Auftrag gegeben bei der NASA,
wo halt geguckt wurde, wie muss eine Raketenarchitektur aussehen,
die vielleicht an die Shuttle-Technologie anklüpfen kann, um Erkundung vom Mond
wieder oder Erkundung noch darüber hinaus mit Astronauten.
Und es ist ganz wichtig gewesen, dass man halt ein großes Programm hat,
um halt die Technologieführerschaft weiterzuführen.
Und dann natürlich werden so Programme dann umdefiniert und auch mal wieder gecancelt.
Und ja, das Artemis-Programm wurde dann, oder das Artemis-Programm,
der Namen vom Artemis-Programm, den gibt's ja eigentlich erst seitdem Donald Trump Präsident war.
Vorher gab es das Orion-Programm, was das Raumschiff war, dann SLS,
dieses Space Launch System.
Das ist das zweite Programm in dem Artemis-Konglomerat.
Und dann gibt es Exploration Ground Systems. Das ist die Startrampe in Florida
und alle weiteren operational Technologien,
Aspekte, die halt dazu nötig sind, so ein Raumschiff zu prozessieren,
den Launcher starten zu lassen, die Kapsel wieder zu bekommen und so weiter.
Artemis hieß vorher Exploration Mission One. Also nicht wirklich ein attraktiver, kein sexy Name.
Und man brauchte dann halt irgendwann, als Donald Trump in Office war, auch einen neuen Namen.
Was aber auch ganz interessant war, war, dass eigentlich der Starttermin wesentlich
später geplant war. Also klar, der Termin war eigentlich immer eher geplant,
aber die Mondlandung war erst für 2028 geplant eigentlich.
Donald Trump hat gesagt, wir müssen das eher machen, wir müssen erst mal Artemis
1 in 2020 fliegen und dann Artemis 3 mit der Mondlandung in 2024.
Damit das noch in seine theoretische zweite Amtszeit fängt.
Das war natürlich nicht offiziell die Position, sondern inoffiziell hatten wir
da so Vermutung, dass das vielleicht damit zusammenhängen könnte.
Auf jeden Fall. Man muss aber auch sagen, das hat vielleicht dem Programm auch
ein bisschen gut getan, weil ein bisschen mehr Funding reingekommen ist.
Also wenn man ja so eine Mission macht, die hat Gesamtkosten und wenn man die
über 10 Jahre oder 15 Jahre ausbereitet, hat man natürlich pro Jahr weniger
Budget. Wenn man das jetzt vier Jahre schneller machen muss,
braucht man pro Jahr mehr Budget.
Und das ist halt auch zum gewissen Teil eingetroffen, dass die NASA in dem Bereich
dann mehr Budget bekommen hat um die halt die Sachen zu beschleunigen und schneller zu machen.
Gut, und das hat dann natürlich zur Folge, dass wir dann 2022.
Mit Artemis 1 gestartet sind.
Atomos 2 ist jetzt geplant für Ende 2024 und für Ende 2025 dann die Mondlandung im Atomos 3 Programm.
Und dazu entwickelt gerade SpaceX das Landesystem.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch mal kurz klar machen, worum es geht.
Also es geht um einen Flug zum Mond und das langfristige Ziel ist halt auch
wieder eine Landung mit Astronauten.
Also das wirklich mal wieder Feet on the Ground herrscht nach dem Apollo.
Deswegen heißt die Mission ja auch Artemis, weil Artemis eben die Zwillingsschwester von Apollo ist.
Das stimmt, ja. Ich finde es immer interessant, wenn sich die Raumfahrt so in
der griechischen Mythologie bedient.
Liegt ja immer nahe, weil ja auch die Sterne danach benannt sind. Orion, ja.
Wobei Artemis und Orion, das habe ich irgendwie ein bisschen nachgelesen.
Da lief es irgendwie nicht so gut. Also ich hoffe, das wird dann nicht zu Problemen führen.
Da kennst du dich in der griechischen Mythologie besser aus als ich.
Ja, das ist noch so eine etwas schwierige Liebe, die am Ende leider immer mit
dem Tod von Orion endete.
Aber das will ich jetzt mal nicht voranstellen.
Ich bin da ganz zuversichtlich, dass er das schon ganz ordentlich plant.
Also, nur um es nochmal klarzumachen.
Also, du hast es ja auch schon erwähnt, SLS, das ist diese Rakete.
Das ist im Prinzip eine Rakete, die erste amerikanische Rakete,
die von der NASA gebaut wurde, die im Prinzip in der Leistungsfähigkeit der
ursprünglichen Saturn V-Rakete,
der Apollo-Mond-Mission mithalten kann, die ja damals und dann eben auch bis
heute eigentlich so mit die stärkste Rakete war, die es überhaupt gab und die
erst jüngst von SpaceX eingeholt wurde in der Leistungsfähigkeit.
Genau, also ich sag mal auch eine Falcon 9, das ist ja diese,
sorry, eine Falcon Heavy, das ist ja diese SpaceX-Rakete mit den drei Boostern,
hat nicht so eine Schubkraft wie ein SLS, das ist noch eine ganz andere Klasse.
Die SLS, die jetzt im November gestartet ist, war wirklich die stärkste Rakete
der Welt vom Startschub her.
Die Nutzlastfähigkeit ist ein bisschen geringer als die Saturn V.
Aber es gibt jetzt auch weitere Ausbaustufen von der Rakete,
die dann wirklich in die Nähe kommen von der Saturn V auch.
Also ich meine, das Artemis-Programm, um das jetzt nochmal mit Apollo zu vergleichen,
Apollo war wirklich First Boots on the Moon Programm.
Okay, wir wollen amerikanische Astronauten.
Auf dem Mond landen. Wir wollen die ersten sein. Dafür wurde ein riesiger nationaler
Aufwand betrieben von Kennedy damals, um das hinzubekommen. Es gab halt unglaubliche
Mittel, die freigesetzt worden sind für das Programm.
Mehrere Prozent des Gesamthaushalts.
Ja, richtig. Es war halt ein National Effort, wie man sagt. Das ist jetzt Artemis nicht unbedingt.
Weil so ein National Effort ist halt auch nicht etwas, was man durchhalten kann für eine lange Zeit.
Dieses Artemis-Programm ist jetzt wirklich längerfristig aufgelegt.
Es gibt schon, sage ich mal, neue Missionen, die geplant sind.
Man möchte nicht nur auf dem Mond landen, sondern auch diese Raumstation im
Mondorbit, der Lunar Gateway, damit aufbauen mit diesen Missionen.
Also wirklich einen Standort zu schaffen, wo man immer wieder hinkehren kann,
wo Infrastruktur entsteht.
Wo quasi eine Orbit-Infrastruktur entsteht, wo man hin kann.
Die ist nicht permanent bemannt, dieser Lunar Gateway.
Kann aber dazu dienen, auf die Mondoberfläche, das ist noch nicht ganz hundertprozentig
klar, aber kann dazu dienen, auf die Mondoberfläche hinunterzukommen.
Der Lunar Gateway wird eine Kommunikationsbrücke sein vom Mond-Orbit zur Erde.
Und ist ein fester Bestandteil der NASA-Artemis-Explorationsarchitektur.
Und dann möchte man natürlich drüber nachdenken, wenn auf der Oberfläche vielleicht
etwas Permanentes entsteht oder sogar eine Lunar Economy,
also eine profitable Mondwirtschaft, was natürlich auch ein bisschen Far Future
ist, dass man dann sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt eine gewisse Infrastruktur im
Orbit, das funktioniert gut,
bauen jetzt noch einen Raumschiff, mit dem wir zum Mars fliegen können.
Das ist das wirklich das langfristige Ziel, man sagt zum Beispiel Artemis Moon to Mars Program.
Na gut, aber wir haben jetzt erstmal, ich denke mal bis Artemis 3,
das ist die Mondlandung, das ist geplant Ende 2025 jetzt offiziell.
Und da müssen wir jetzt erstmal gucken, dass wir das hinbekommen,
dass SpaceX auch das Landesystem fertig hat, mit dem wir dann docken werden.
Und danach gibt es dann die Mission zum Aufbau des Gateways.
Da leistet die ESA natürlich auch einen großen Beitrag.
Also wir haben zwei Module, die gerade auch schon in Auftrag sind und gebaut
werden für diese Raumstation am Mond.
Und die werden dann mit Orion sozusagen zum Mond geflogen.
Um vielleicht noch mal die Begrifflichkeiten von vornherein klar zu machen.
Also Artemis ist sozusagen der Name für das gesamte Projekt.
Wir haben dann 1, 2, 3 die einzelnen Missionen, an denen dann die Entwicklung
dieses Projekts sich festmacht.
An den wichtigen Komponenten haben wir die Startrakete, die SLS,
wie ich gerade schon beschrieben.
Starkes, dickes Teil, kann einfach eine Menge Schub erzeugen,
der halt auch einfach erforderlich ist, um einfach bis zum Mond zu kommen.
Das ist jetzt eben nicht so mit, wir fliegen mal zur ISS, 400 Kilometer, haha.
Das kriegen wir schon mittlerweile auf einer Arschpacke abgesessen,
aber um die großen Geschwindigkeiten zu erzeugen, braucht man eben schon nochmal
andere Sachen. Zumindest für diese Nutzlast.
Wir haben ja auch solche Missionen gehabt, wie zum Pluto zum Beispiel.
Das bedurfte ja auch einiger Geschwindigkeit, um dort sehr schnell hinzukommen,
aber trotzdem die Nutzlast war halt nicht im Ansatz so groß,
wie das jetzt der Fall ist.
Ja, richtig. zeichnet sich durchaus, dass man halt einen relativ hohen Geschwindigkeitsbedarf
hat, also dieses Delta V, was durch die Rakete bereitgestellt werden muss.
Und gleichzeitig hohe Massen von dem Raumschiff, also wir haben halt ein Raumschiff,
was im Endeffekt Astronauten beherbergt und komplettes Lebenserhaltungssystem für die Astronauten,
selber auch noch Manöver durchführen muss, durchführen können muss.
Genau und das ist Orion. Das wollen wir nochmal sagen. Also wir haben die Rakete
SLS. Wir haben Orion und Orion besteht im Prinzip eigentlich auch aus zwei Teilen.
Nämlich einerseits aus der Kapsel, wo eben Astronauten dann später drin sitzen
sollen und die dann auch wieder zurückkehrt, als einzige zurückkehrt.
Aber damit das irgendwie funktioniert, gibt es noch ein Service-Modul,
sozusagen Technik und Antriebssystem,
was diese Menschenkapsel letzten Endes durch den Weltraum drückt und das ist
dann auch gleich unser Fokus, aber das ist dann sozusagen der dritte wichtige technische Teil.
Diese drei Komponenten machen im Wesentlichen das H-SMIS für die erste Mission so aus.
Genau, richtig und auch, ich meine, bei NASA gibt's halt noch ein drittes Projekt,
das ist dieses Exploration Ground System Programm, die halt wirklich auch den
neuen Startramper jetzt bauen.
Für Artemis 3 brauchen wir einen neuen Startramper und so weiter.
Also das ist auch nochmal ein signifikantes Projekt,
was man nicht so richtig mitkriegt, weil wir haben halt den Launcher SLS,
wie du schon richtig sagtest, eine Riesenentwicklung gewesen,
der übrigens halt viel von der Technologie vom Shuttle übernommen hat.
Wir haben die Haupttriebwerke vom Shuttle, also die Wasserstoff-Sauerstofftriebwerke,
die da setzten, vier Stück vorne in der Hauptstufe und dann eine vergrößerte
Version der Booster, die halt wirklich den Hauptschub beim Start liefern.
Und dann in weiteren Ausbaustufen wird dann noch eine neue Oberstufe konzipiert für Artemis IV.
Die Exploration Upper Stage, mit der dann halt noch mehr Masse zum Mondorbit gebracht werden kann.
Genau zum Aufbau dieser Raumstation, weil da braucht man Orion plus dieses Modul
von der Station. Das ist natürlich eine größere Masse als nur Orion,
das Raumschiff selber, was ungefähr 25 Tonnen wiegt.
Also 25 Tonnen Nutzlast soll letzten Endes hin.
Also Orion selber hat 25 Tonnen, das ist ja die Nutzlast vom SLS.
Und dann, ich bin nicht 100% sicher, aber so ein Gateway-Modul wird wahrscheinlich
auch zwischen 8 und 10 Tonnen wiegen.
Und das ist dann halt auch auf der Oberstufe oder auf der SLS-Rakete drauf in
der Ausbau-Stufe mit der neuen Oberstufe.
Ja, das ist eine Menge Holz.
Das ist eine Menge Holz, gerade für den Mond-Orbit. Deswegen braucht man auch so große Raketen.
Genau.
Also, Nutzlasten sollte man sich schon mal klar machen. Also eine Ariane 5 hat,
glaube ich, so eine Nutzlast von 5 Tonnen?
Ne, mit 10. 10 bis 10. 10? GTO, ja.
Okay.
Also bis zum Geostationary Transfer Orbit sind es so 10.
Mhm.
Genau, da können die zwei Satelliten 5 Tonnen oder so unterbringen.
Ariane 6 wird in der gleichen Größenordnung sein, 6-4.
Mhm.
Ja, das sind aber Raketen, mit denen man nicht unbedingt viel,
vielleicht in der Ausbaustufe auch, vielleicht so acht Tonnen bis zum Mond kriegen
könnte, acht bis zehn Tonnen ungefähr, aber halt nicht die Größenordnung,
um da halt ein komplett bemanntes System hinzuschicken.
Gut, dann schauen wir doch mal genauer auf die Orion-Komponente,
die ja eben aus zwei Teilen besteht.
Blicken wir vielleicht erst mal kurz auf das ja eigentlich
noch zukünftige System was aber jetzt eben auch
schon getestet wurde die Kapsel für
den human space flight also wo die astronauten letzten ende ist
drin reisen im prinzip verfolgt man hier ein ähnliches konzept wie bei apollo
so ein zweigeteiltes modul das heißt es gibt eben den teil wo die menschen drin
sind wo dann halt temperatur sauerstoff etc alles also wo sozusagen Sachen gemütlich
sein muss, sodass man da drin leben kann.
Und dann gibt es halt diesen Serviceteil, der eben das alles bereitstellt und
wo die Antriebstechnik mit drin ist. Und so war das ja bei Apollo auch.
Genau. Und am Ende war es so, dass das, was halt auf dem Mond gelandet ist,
diese Kapsel, wird dann halt abgespalten, kann dann selber wieder starten und
verbindet sich wieder mit diesem Serviceteil.
Also Apollo hatte ja, das muss man auch noch sagen, Apollo hatte ja noch eine
dritte Komponente, das ist die Landefähre.
Die gibt es jetzt bei Orion noch nicht, die wird ja gerade entwickelt und soll
dann separat bei Artemis 3 schon im Mondorbit vorhanden sein,
mit der dann Orion, das Raumschiff Orion, was dann mit dem SNS wieder gelounge
wurde, dockt und dann diese Landefähre, die von bei 6 gebaut wird die soll dann auf dem Mond landen.
Die Astronauten werden dann einige Zeit auf dem Mond ihre Experimente machen
und dann wieder in dieser Landefähre einsteigen,
wieder in den Mondorbit fliegen, wo sie dann auf Orion umsteigen und mit Orion
dann wieder zurück zur Erde fliegen. Das ist das Artemis-3-Szenario.
Im Vergleich zu Apollo, natürlich ein bisschen anders, weil die Landefähre,
also die Eagle, war ja immer auf der Saturn V Rakete mit dabei.
Also da gab es ein Service Modul, da gab es das Command oder das Crew Module
und diese dieser Landefähre.
Und im Vergleich zu Apollo, im Apollo waren ja drei Astronauten,
die mitfliegen konnten und ich glaube die Lebensdauer der Capsula beziehungsweise
die die Missionsdauer war halt durch durch das Lebenserhaltungssystem beschränkt.
Ich hoffe, da sage ich jetzt nichts Falsches. Das war glaube ich zwei Wochen,
wo die halt die Mission durchführen können. Das können wir wesentlich länger
mit Orion, Die Kapsel ist so ausgelegt, dass die Astronauten länger supportet werden können.
Und wir können vier Astronauten mitfliegen. Das hat natürlich zur Folge,
dass die Kapsel auch wesentlich größer ist im Durchmesser.
Orion ist ja typisch so eine chronische Kapsel für so ein Wiedereintrittskörper.
Sie hat einen Durchmesser von ungefähr fünf Meter und somit auch das größte
Hitzeschutzschild, das jemals geflogen worden ist.
Das ist auch eine technologische Meisterleistung, dieses Hitzeschutzschild.
Also das Hitzeschild vom Space Shuttle war aber noch größer.
Ja, gut, aber für so eine kleine, natürlich das war wesentlich größer,
aber für halt so eine runde, konische Kapsel unten auch.
Wir haben ja auch beim Space Shuttle nun wieder Eintritt vom Low Earth Orbit
und da sind die Geschwindigkeiten ja nochmal kleiner. Wenn wir vom Mond wiederkommen
haben, wir haben am Ende glaube ich 40.000 Kilometer pro Stunde gehabt und vom
Leo hat man ungefähr 25.000 Kilometer pro Stunde.
Ja, und das ist dann nochmal ein großer Unterschied in der Wärme,
also in der Peak Heat Load,
aber auch in der integralen Wärmestrom, dass man halt da das Hitzeschutzschild
dann für auslegen muss, um halt die Astronauten sicher dann zum Mond zu bringen.
Hitzeschutzschild und ich glaube auch, die eigentliche Flugbahn ist auch nochmal angepasst worden.
Die Flugbahn, da kann ich gleich nochmal beim Missionsverlauf zu kommen,
aber die Flugbahn ist ein bisschen angepasst worden im Vergleich zu Apollo.
Das Programm ist industriell so aufgebaut, dass die NASA als Missionshauptverordnete,
die haben Lockheed Martin, im Boot, um das Orion-Raumschiff zu bauen.
Die ESA hat dann mit NASA ein Memorandum of Understanding,
also quasi so eine Art zwischen Regierungs- oder Intergovernmental-Vertrag,
um diese europäischen Service-Module an die zu liefern und die werden dann von
Lockheed Martin ins Gesamtraumschiff integriert.
Also wir haben das Crewmodul, was halt in Amerika produziert wird,
das europäische Service Modul, was dann in die USA geliefert wird und dann gibt
es diesen Crewmodule Adapter,
das ist sage ich mal so ein Ring, weil der Durchmesser vom Crewmodul ist größer
als der Durchmesser vom Service Modul und dann gibt es quasi einen Ring,
der nochmal auf das Service Modul gesetzt wird, was dann das Crewmodul aufnehmen
kann. Adapter. So eine Art Adapter, genau.
Aber auch mit dem Release Mechanismus, also den Mechanismus,
um die Kapsel nachher vom Service Modul zu trennen. Das wird auch von Lockheed
Martin konzipiert und gebaut.
Das ist natürlich von der industriellen Seite eine sehr...
Spannende Aufgabe und der Airbus ist unser Hauptauftragnehmer.
Airbus in Bremen. Die Firma hat eine sehr gute Historie im Bereich bemannte Raumfahrt.
Kolumbusmodul wurde dort konzipiert
und gebaut. Es gibt verschiedene Projekte, die da laufen zur ISS.
Und auch ATV wurde mit Bremen, mit Airbus Bremen, auch mit Airbus Limerot bei
Paris konzipiert und gebaut.
Es wurden ja auch fünf erfolgreichen Missionen von ATV geflogen.
ATV, das heißt Automated Transfer Vehicle, das war eine der europäischen Beiträge
zu Internationalen Raumstationen.
Das ist ein Versorgungsschiff, das von der Ariane 5-Rakete in Kourou gestartet
wurde und was dann autonom an die Raumstation docken konnte.
An der Raumstation und dann Versorgung mit Treibstoff, Wasser,
Experimenten, Lebensmittel und so weiter für die Astronauten durchführen konnten.
Hatte ich im Übrigen auch hier schon bei Raumzeit behandelt, lang ist es her.
Im Mai 2011, als ich hier zu Gast war, das erste Mal, habe ich mit Nico Dettmann
gesprochen über das ATV und eben diese fünf Missionen, die dort gerade,
das war noch gerade so die Zeit des letzten Space Shuttle-Flugs.
Genau, da war das ATV dann gemeinsam mit dem Space Shuttle einer ISS dran.
Da gab es schöne Bilder, ja.
Da gab es schöne Bilder, auf jeden Fall. Genau, so ein Prinzip.
Die Technologie des ATV war dann ebenso die Grundlage für dieses europäische Service-Modul,
was eben jetzt der wesentliche europäische Beitrag ist, kann man sagen.
Aber das QModul wird jetzt wo gebaut?
Also integriert wird es im Kennedy Space Center. Da gibt es dieses Operations
and Checkout-Gebäude im Kennedy Space Center, wo auch schon Apollo integriert wurde.
Und das ist jetzt quasi unter Verantwortung, diese Integration ist unter Verantwortung
von Lockheed Martin. Und da wird das Crewmodul zusammengebaut.
Aber das eigentliche Modul wird in Deutschland gebaut?
Das europäische Service-Modul wird in Bremen gebaut.
Aber ich meine, das Crewmodul.
Das Crewmodul wird ja in Amerika gebaut. gebaut.
Ok, das wird in Amerika gebaut. Und integriert wird das natürlich auch alles
in Amerika. Das heißt, hier kommt das Service Modul dazu, wird über den Teich
gefahren und wird dann wahrscheinlich hier erstmal nochmal vorher gecheckt.
Also wir machen einen kompletten Abnahmetest bei Airbus in Bremen.
Also das ist ein langer Prozess über mehrere Monate. Werden alle Systeme in
dem Service Modul wirklich funktional durchgecheckt.
Größere Tests für die Qualifikation von dem Service Modul,
aber auch von dem QModul, die haben in Amerika stattgefunden,
weil man das auch in der Konfiguration testen musste, wo das QModul mit dem
Service Modul verbunden war, zum Beispiel ein Thermal-Test oder ein Struktur-Test und so weiter.
Das wurde dann auch schon vor einigen Jahren in Amerika durchgeführt,
aber jetzt wirklich für die einzelnen Module, die ausgeliefert werden.
Also 2018 haben wir zum Beispiel schon das erste europäische Service Modul an die NASA geliefert.
Nach einem langen Abnahmetest, wo wirklich diese funktionalen Ketten,
die das Raumschiff hat. Also ich fange vielleicht mal an kurz über die Architektur
von dem Service Modul zu sprechen.
Ja, dann kommen wir mal auf das Service Modul zu sprechen.
Das ist ja auch das Hauptthema heute.
Das Service-Modul hat im Wesentlichen die folgenden Funktionen.
Es ist dazu da, das Crew-Modul zu unterstützen, die Astronauten am Leben zu
halten und alle wichtigen Funktionen im Orbit durchzuführen.
Wir haben zum ersten das Antriebssystem, was die Manöver für die Orbitkontrolle,
Orbitänderungen und für die Lagerregelung durchführen kann.
Dann haben wir das Thermalsystem, was das Service Modul selber thermisch konditioniert,
also auf Temperatur hält.
Im Weltraum hat man ja das Problem, dass man auf der einen Seite die heiße Sonne
hat, die quasi ungebremst auf das Raumschiff strahlt und auf der Rückseite quasi
Vakuum und schwarze Leere, die halt wirklich sehr kalt ist. Dazu braucht man ein Thermalsystem.
Um das auszugleichen und zu kontrollieren. Aber das Thermalsystem hat auch eine
Schnittstelle mit dem Crewmodul und
das übernimmt dann sozusagen auch den Thermalhaushalt für das Crewmodul,
das ja so noch um sich schön angenehm temperiert da oben bewegen können.
Dann haben wir das Power-System, also das System für die Stromerzeugung.
Das ist quasi auch mit Historie von ATV.
Und auch ganz interessant, wir befinden uns jetzt hier in Nordwijk in den Niederlanden.
Das ist eine kleine Küstenstadt, die neben Leiden ist. Das ist vielleicht ein
bisschen größere Stadt.
Und da hat Airbus zum Beispiel eine Filiale in Leiden, die die Solarpanele herstellen für das Raumschiff.
Das heißt, interessanterweise kommen diese großen Solarpanele,
die an einem Service-Modul dran sind, die ungefähr 14 Kilowatt an elektrischer Leistung produzieren.
Hier aus Holland und werden dann in Kennedy erst integriert in das Raumschiff.
Das ist diese ikonische X-Wing-Anordnung, wie man das bei ATV...
Richtig, die wurde dann einfach übernommen aus Gründen, dass man sagt,
wir müssen halt die Architektur, wir müssen halt viel von der Architektur und
den Komponenten vom ATV...
Wie viel macht das aus? Also einerseits, wie viel Prozent der ATV-Technik ist
sozusagen wirklich mehr oder weniger 1 zu 1 übernommen worden?
Und wie viel ist konzeptionell übernommen worden? Wie anders ist das Service-Modul?
Also das Service-Modul ist natürlich schon komplett anders von der Architektur
her, wie das ATV. Das ATV war halt ein System, das bis zur Raumstation geflogen
ist und hat da auch einen bedrückten Teil, weil das hat ja gedockt.
Also der Docking-Mechanismus zum Beispiel ist am Service-Modul nicht dran,
der ist ja im Pro-Modul dran bei Artemis.
Und hat halt diesen bedrückten Teil, damit auch Astronauten reinlaufen können.
Das haben wir jetzt zum Beispiel nicht.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel gab es ein Thermalsubsystem.
Also mit gedrücktem Teil, dass man es unter Druck setzen kann, weil es ist ja Cargo.
Genau, also der Cargo muss natürlich, man sagt ja auch bedrückten und unbedruckten
Teil, im Raumschiff, der bedrückte Teil, im Raum gibt es ja nur Vakuum.
Das heißt, ein Teil vom Raumschiff ist dann wirklich im Vakuum.
Und der bedrückte Teil ist dann da, wo die Astronauten reinlaufen können, wenn es angedockt ist.
Und wie bei beim ESM, beim Europäischen Service Modul auch, gibt es halt dieses
Lebenserhaltungssystem und auch bei Beatemis braucht man das, also mit Luft.
Das heißt, wir haben halt Stickstoff- und Sauerstofftanks an Bord im Service-Modul
und auch Wassertanks, die halt für den täglichen Bedarf der Astronauten sind.
Das ist halt dann über die Schnittstellen verbunden mit dem Crew-Modul.
Aber diesen Crew-Moduladapter, der von Lockheed noch angebaut wird,
also immer von der Architektur her ist das Service-Modul schon sehr anders wie das ATV.
Wo man konnte halt viele Komponenten übernehmen, zum Beispiel unsere Hilfstriebwerke.
Im Antriebssystem sind die gleichen, die bei ATV geflogen sind.
Die Solarpanele sind sehr ähnlich und auch auf Systemebene gibt es Vergleichbarkeiten
für das Thermalsystem und für das Lebenshaltungssystem.
Das consumable storage system heißt das heißt es
bei uns immer europäischen service modus na
ja wie gesagt also das ist auch ich sag mal ein bisschen vielleicht auf
der ebene wenn man so ein projekt aufsetzt dass man versucht diese ähnlichkeiten
zu einem vorhandenen system herauszustellen um dann entsprechend auch das war
nicht dafür zu bekommen dass man so eine gewisse kontinuität auf technologie
ebene darstellen kann nach dem motto das haben wir doch alle schon erfunden
das haben wir alle schon erfunden das brauchen anpassen genau das Das muss man ein bisschen anpassen.
Das ist ja bei der NASA nichts anderes. Sie sagen, wir bauen einen Launcher
basierend auf einem Shuttle.
Im Endeffekt auch ein komplett neues System und die Hauptkomponenten mussten auch angepasst werden.
Klar, die Haupttriebwerke sind die gleichen geworden, aber auch Delta qualifiziert.
Also nochmal neu getestet, werden auf einen anderen Betriebspunkt gefahren.
Das ist etwas, um zu sagen, wir haben gewisse Industrien, gewisse Komponenten,
die vorhanden sind und die nehmen wir halt ins neue Programm mit.
Das macht ja auch Sinn. Ich meine, das ist ja auf der einen Seite,
wenn man jetzt wirklich, im Extremfall würde ja Technik eins zu eins übernommen werden.
Weil man weiß, diese Komponente funktioniert, die reicht jetzt auch in ihrer
Spezifikation für das neue Projekt aus, dann nehmen wir das genauso.
Wenn die Spezifikation jetzt nicht ausreicht, dann kann man aber zumindest sagen,
aber das Prinzip haben wir schon mal getestet. Wir wissen, dass es grundsätzlich
funktioniert. Wir müssen jetzt hier nicht nochmal irgendwie einen Prototypen
schaffen, wo wir uns im Vorfeld vielleicht unklar sind, ob das überhaupt so funktioniert.
Und wir wissen, dass da auch genug Luft nach oben ist, weil wir es damals eigentlich
gar nicht in das Maximum genutzt haben, aber vielleicht schon mal auf das Maximum getestet haben, etc.
Das sind solche Sachen. Und diese Erfahrung, die dann halt auch damit drinsteckt,
die ist natürlich auch was wert, die muss dann nicht in Ausbildung gesteckt werden etc.
Und forschen. Ja, richtig. Man will natürlich immer auf Komponenten zurückgreifen.
Ich sag mal, es ist halt vielleicht nicht vergleichbar wie jetzt zum Beispiel
ein Bulli aus der Automobilbranche.
Man kann halt mit dem Bulli immer verschiedene Sachen machen.
Da kann man Leute reinsetzen, da kann man aber auch Pakete mit transportieren
oder ein Handwerker kann damit seine Arbeit machen.
Bei der Raumfahrt ist es natürlich so, dass diese Missionsanforderungen,
die wir haben, es gibt halt eine Mission zum Mars, es gibt eine Mission zum
Mond, es gibt eine Mission zur Raumstation, es gibt eine Mission zum Pluto.
Diese Missionsanfahrungen haben einen extremen Einfluss auf die Architektur
von einem System. In dieser Architektur können dann Komponenten drin sein,
die vorher schon mal geflogen sind. Das will man natürlich auch immer machen.
Also Entwicklungskosten, auch für Komponenten, sind im Raumfahrtbereich sehr hoch.
Wenn man ein neues Triebwerk entwickeln müsste, ist man einen sehr hohen Betrag los.
Natürlich ist es auch wichtig, dass man das macht und dann auch ein bisschen
die Leistungsfähigkeit dieser Komponenten weiterzubringen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, man muss auch nicht das Rad neu erfinden,
gerade auf Komponentenseite.
Man muss gucken, ob man da jetzt mit dem Vorhandenen schon seine Architektur aufbauen kann.
Und das macht man ja generell eigentlich in vielen Industrien, dass man versucht,
das zu benutzen, was schon da ist, was ja auch bewährt ist, was eine gewisse
Qualität hat und wo man vielleicht eventuell auch den den Nutzungsbereich erweitern
kann durch weitere Tests und so weiter, das ist dann jetzt auch kein großer Aufwand.
Beziehst du dich jetzt eigentlich auch auf das Triebwerk? Weil ich meine,
die Anforderungen für den Antrieb sind ja dann jedoch etwas höher als bei der
Mission nur zu ISS, oder?
Ja, also ich sage mal, vielleicht kann ich da jetzt nochmal,
weil das ist ja mein Fachgebiet, so ein bisschen auf das Antriebssystem eingehen.
In dem ESM sind insgesamt 33 Triebwerke eingebaut.
24 davon sind für die Lagerregelung von dem Orion Raumschiff.
Acht sind die Hilfstriebwerke und die werden benutzt oder die sollen benutzt
werden, wenn zum Beispiel das Haupttriebwerk nicht benutzt werden kann oder ausfällt.
Und das Haupttriebwerk, das heißt, diese 27 Kilonewton-Triebwerk relativ groß
für ein Raumschiff, das ist das alte Orbitaltriebwerk vom Shuttle.
Und dieses Triebwerk, das da eingebaut ist, dieses OMSI, also Orbital Maneuvering
System Engine, das Triebwerk, das kommt wirklich auch aus dem Shuttle.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, was bei Artemis I geflogen ist, aber bei Artemis
III ist ein Triebwerk von Atlantis eingebaut.
Das sind wirklich wiederaufbereitete Triebwerke, die schon mal im Orbit gewesen sind.
Und das ist unser Haupttrieb. Die werden von Ariane Group in Lampolzhausen gebaut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du da schon mal von gehört hast, von der Firma?
Da war ich sogar schon mal.
Da warst du schon mal. Ich habe mir schon fast gedacht, du kennst dich wahrscheinlich
besser aus in der Raumfahrtsphäre in Europa als ich.
Du hast eigentlich alles gesehen. Da habe ich über Raketenantriebe gesprochen,
eine der ersten Sendungen überhaupt.
Ja, guck mal, dann kennst du auch die Spezies da. Das ist eine ziemlich bekannte
Firma im Raumfahrtsektor auch,
die natürlich die Ariane Rakete herstellt und vermarktet, aber auch gerade auf
dem Triebwerksektor oder Komponentensektor sehr viel Know-how hat und da auch
gute Produkte liefern kann.
Und diese Lageregelungs-Triebwerke, die waren auch schon bei ATV im Einsatz.
Und dann diese Hilftriebwerke, die werden von Aerojet in Kalifornien gebaut.
Das ist eine bekannte amerikanische Firma, die die Raumfahrtantriebe herstellt.
Und dieses Triebwerk geht schon zurück im gewissen Maße auf die Apollo-Zeiten.
Das ist dann von der Triebwerkseite das System.
Dann braucht man natürlich viel Treibstoff, wenn man zum Mond fliegen will und
am Mond was machen möchte.
Von diesen 25 Tonnen Gesamtraumschiffmasse von Oranien sind ungefähr 8,5 Tonnen Treibstoff sein.
Krass.
Also sehr viel. Das ist lagerfähiger Treibstoff, der für alle Triebwerke benutzt
wird. Das ist quasi in der Mitte von dem Service Modul haben wir vier große Treibstofftanks.
Die werden von Ariane Group in Bremen hergestellt.
Das ist eine Firma, die da auch sehr viel Know-how und Historie hat auf dem
Bereich von Raumschifftanks.
Dann brauchen wir, also wie sowas funktioniert bei diesen Raumschift-Triebwerken heutzutage.
Das ist eigentlich state of the art. Es gibt Entwicklungen, um das auch anders zu machen.
Man hat einen Hochdruckteil, in dem ein ernährtes Gas gelagert wird.
Also in unserem Fall Helium, also wir haben zwei Hochdruck.
Was heißt, ernährtes Gas?
Ja, also nicht reaktionsfähig mit anderen Stoffen.
Also zum Beispiel, ne ne, also gerade es kann halt einfach nicht reagieren,
zum Beispiel Stickstoff oder Helium jetzt in dem Fall. In unserem System benutzen wir Helium.
Da sind dann zwei Tanks in dem Raumschiff bei 400 Bar.
Und dann haben wir eine wirklich sehr komplizierte Bedrückungsarchitektur,
also ganz viele Ventile, mit denen dann dieses Hochdruckgas in diese Treibstofftanks geleitet wird.
Und dann wird quasi der Treibstoff rausgedrückt aus den Tanks zu den Triebwerken hin.
Das heißt, wenn die Triebwerke Treibstoff gebrauchen, dann fließt dieser Treibstoff
aus den Treibstofftanks raus und somit verringert sich der Druck in diesen Tanks.
Da muss man von oben wieder Gas nachgeben, dass das System permanent im gewissen
Druckbereich sich befindet.
Und dafür benutzt man das Helium?
Dafür benutzt man das Helium, genau. Das ist bei vielen Satelliten so,
dass es dann für diese lagerfähigen Treibstoffe, gibt es eine Bedrückungsarchitektur.
Um sozusagen den Tankdruck immer auf dem richtigen Level zu haben.
Diese Triebwerke funktionieren halt nur im gewissen Druckbereich.
Dafür ist Helium natürlich insofern optimal, dass es natürlich wirklich das
reaktionsunfreudigste Gas überhaupt ist. Also es ist der absolute Langweiler im Weltall.
Andererseits ist Helium auch sehr schwierig zu speichern eigentlich.
Ja, also ich sag mal, Helium geht noch. Ich glaube, bei Wasserstoff wird es dann spannend.
Also Helium ist ein der leichtesten oder zweitleichtesten Gas.
Dementsprechend flüchtig, aber normalerweise. Wir haben natürlich Probleme mit Dichtheit.
Das ist immer ein Problem in einem System, wo Fluide sind, also Gase und Flüssigkeiten.
Aber das wird von Airbus natürlich alles vorher getestet.
Das hat man im Griff. Gerade externe Leckage tritt eigentlich so nicht auf.
Das wäre ja auch schlecht, wenn man im Orbit ist und man plötzlich wieder Gas
oder Treibstoff verliert. Dann hätte man wieder so ein Apollo 13 Szenario und
das möchte man natürlich vermeiden.
Aber gut, das wird natürlich alles vorher getestet, auch mehrmals,
dass so etwas nicht auftreten kann.
Das ganze System ist dann voller Ventile, sag ich mal. Man muss ja dann auch
den Treibstoff entsprechend zu den verschiedenen Triebwerken hinleiten.
Da gibt es dann verschiedene Ventile, die dafür da sind in dem System.
Typischerweise werden die Rohrleitungen im System auch geheizt,
um vorzubeugen, dass der Treibstoff einfriert.
Wie gesagt, im Weltraum ist ja eine extreme Bedingung. Es kann ja wieder ganz
heiß sein oder ganz kalt. Und natürlich wäre es für das Antriebssystem sehr
schlecht, wenn der Treibstoff einfriert, weil dann kommt keiner mehr am Triebwerk selber an.
Dann glättet man da oben rum und wartet bis vielleicht wieder aufgetaut ist,
aber das ist natürlich auch nicht so einfach, gerade wenn es ein permanentes Problem ist.
Und wie gesagt, dann um dieses Antriebssystem zu qualifizieren,
hat die ESA dann im Rahmen des Projektes ein ein Qualifikationsmodul,
also ein Antriebssystemqualifikationsmodul in Auftrag ergeben.
Das wurde damals bei OHB, das ist ja auch ein deutscher Raumfahrtkonzern mit
verschiedenen Niederlassung auch in verschiedenen europäischen Ländern bei OAB Schweden.
Dieses Antriebssystem Qualifikationsmodul in Auftrag gegeben,
was quasi ein Nachbau des wirklichen Flugantriebssystems ist,
um damit halt zu zeigen, dass alle Manöver geflogen werden können.
Dieses Modell wurde dann nach zu NASA, nach White Sands in New Mexico geflogen.
WhiteSands Test Facility, das ist eine Einrichtung der NASA,
die mitten in der New-Mexican-Desert ist.
Da wurden auch schon das Apollo-Antriebssystem getestet und auch zum Beispiel
dieses Triebwerk vom Shuttle. Also alle lagerfähigen Antriebssystemtests werden
da in WhiteSands durchgeführt.
Dann haben wir über Jahre dieses Antriebssystem getestet. Die letzten Tests
haben, glaube ich, 2020 noch stattgefunden.
Und so macht man das eigentlich vom Prinzip her. Man hat die Komponenten auf
Komponenten-Eben, die man qualifiziert und so testet, dass sie der Anwendung entsprechen.
Und das Gleiche macht man dann für das Subsystem auch, dass man dann Tests durchführt,
wo man dann zum Beispiel mal eine komplette Mission durchläuft,
wo man halt alle Triebwerke feuert,
wo man das Haupttriebwerk mal für 10-15 Minuten anhat und den kompletten Sprit unten rausjagt,
um zu zeigen, mein System mit der Bedrückungsarchitektur kann so einen Burn
supporten und gleichzeitig auch noch Lageregelung machen.
Wie viel Redundanz ist in diesem System?
Ja gut, wir haben eigentlich eine Federtoleranz auf allen funktionalen Ketten.
Was heißt das?
Man kann halt einen Fehler haben.
Und man kann trotzdem noch die Mission zu Ende fliegen. Man wird dann zwar in
einer Situation sein, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt haben wir da einen Fehler,
der nächste Fehler könnte eventuell fatal sein, wir fliegen jetzt nach Hause.
Das wird dann die... Also im selben System. Im selben System.
Nicht insgesamt ein Fehler und dann ist vorbei, sondern pro Subsystem.
Aber das Problem ist ja bei dieser Sache, wenn man jetzt in einem System einen
Fehler hat, kann der nächste Fehler wieder auch in dem gleichen System auftreten.
Das ist ja nicht gesagt, dass das dann im anderen ist. Das heißt,
normalerweise, wenn man einen Fehler hat und man hat nicht irgendwie anders
noch eine Redundanz, die irgendwo herkommt.
Es gibt auch Fälle, da hat man mal doppelte Redundanz drin aus irgendwelchen
Gründen oder man hat eine operationelle Redundanz, dass man sagen könnte,
okay, das Teil steht jetzt nicht zur Verfügung, aber wir können es auch anders machen.
Normalerweise ist das dann ein Fall für loss of mission. Das heißt,
man muss dann nach Hause fliegen, wirklich.
Weil der nächste Fehler kann ja wieder da in dem System auftreten,
sodass es dann nicht mehr zur Verfügung stehen würde.
Aber einen Fehler können wir auf allen Systemen tolerieren. Okay.
Das heißt, im Triebwerkssystem gibt es alles zweimal. Genau.
Deswegen gibt es auch zum Beispiel diese Hilfstriebwerke. Das ist jetzt mal
ein Beispiel, wo man das gut illustrieren kann. Wir haben das Haupttriebwerk,
dieses OMSI-Triebwerk vom Shuttle.
Wenn das aus irgendwelchen Gründen mal ausfällt, ein Ventil geht nicht auf oder
so was, hat man halt diese Hilfstriebwerke.
Acht Stück an der Zahl, mit denen dann diese Hauptmanöver geflogen werden können.
Natürlich ist die Brennzeit dann länger.
Weil die nicht so viel Schub haben. Genau. Aber die sind so ausgelegt,
das System ist so ausgelegt natürlich, um solche Manöver auch zu supporten.
Das heißt, anders gesprochen, was halt nicht passieren darf,
ist zum Beispiel Haupttriebwerk fällt aus und die Selbsttriebwerke fallen aus.
Das geht ja nicht. Dann hat man natürlich ein Problem. Aber das sind ja zwei
Fehler, die dann in dem gleichen System auftreten würden. Das gleiche auch bei
den Lageregelungstriebwerken.
Also die sind komplett voneinander getrennt redundant. Wenn da auf einer Seite
von dem Langerungstriebwerk eine Lackage entsteht,
kann man zum Beispiel dann dieses Triebwerk isolieren, die Ventile zu machen,
die zu diesem Triebwerk hinführen und dann einfach das redundante Triebwerk dazu benutzen.
Und dann muss man dann gucken, ob das wirklich dann schon Fall ist,
um nach Hause zu fliegen oder nicht.
Also im Prinzip ja, aber vielleicht kann man das dann operationell irgendwie
umgehen, das ist dann noch nicht nötig. Aber das ist dann so eine Sache,
die dann im Detail sich angeguckt werden kann.
Ja, höhere Redundanzen gibt es ja meistens nur bei Missionen,
die jetzt wirklich viele, viele Jahrzehnte im Einsatz sein könnten,
im Idealfall oder zumindest so.
Oder eben sehr weit weg sind und nicht die Option haben, mal eben wieder nach Hause zu fliegen.
Redundanzen sind wichtig natürlich, weil wir Astronauten an Bord haben.
Deswegen macht man das ja auch so und damit beschränkt man dann sein Risiko
und erhöht seine Reliability.
Das ist natürlich ganz wichtig bei so einem System. Es können viele Fehler auftreten,
aber man muss halt nachweisen beim Entwurf von so einem Raumschiff,
dass man mit einer gewissen Reliability die Mission zu Ende fliegen kann.
Das ist wichtig. Das muss auf allen Ebenen gezeigt werden.
Und ich sag mal, es gibt glaube ich,
wie gesagt, vom Pro-Modul her habe ich so ein beschränktes Wissen,
weil natürlich das Pro-Modul in Amerika gebaut wird und wir quasi durch diese
Export-Control-Geschichte da jetzt auch keine gute Visibility haben, was das angeht.
Aber zum Beispiel von dem Flugcomputer her, was ja wirklich ein zentrales Ding
ist, da gibt es eine höhere Renundanz. Also nicht für alle Systeme,
aber zum Beispiel für das Antriebssystem.
Kommen wir mal auf die Artemis-1-Mission, die jetzt gelaufen ist im letzten November.
Der Start hat sich ja relativ lange verzögert, gegenüber zwei Monate?
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin am Anfang 2018 hier im Projekt angefangen.
Seitdem ich das eigentlich immer sehe, ist es schon in sechs Monaten.
Das ist natürlich nicht eingetreten, wie man weiß. Wir sind ja im November jetzt gestartet.
Gut, aber das erste ernste Datum war eigentlich Februar 2022.
Bis man dann auch gesehen hat, okay, es wird schwierig, weil die Hauptstufe der SLS-Rakete,
die wurde auch nochmal komplett getestet, also die geflogen ist,
wurde quasi am Boden einmal komplett durchgetestet, man hat die Komplette,
ja, hat sie komplett betankt und komplett entleert über acht Minuten burnen,
um einfach zu zeigen, okay mit der Stufe können wir die Mission fliegen,
das ist unser Qualifikationstest.
Ja und da gab es dann auch wirklich Verzögerungen und dann wurde die Stufe halt von,
das ist im Süden der USA, ich weiß gar nicht in welchem Bundesstaat,
das ist auf jeden Fall, wo dann erstmal per Bar Kasse dann diese Stufe nach
Kennedy gebracht und musste dann da integriert werden mit den Boostern und so weiter.
So ein langwieriger Prozess. Und das hat dann schon mal dieses Februar Datum
weiter ins Frühjahr geschoben.
Also es ist deshalb verzögert worden, weil man nochmal einen Test machen wollte,
den man so vorher nicht eingeplant hat?
Der war geplant und bei dem Test gab es einen Abbruch nach einer Minute ungefähr.
Da wurde halt ein Sensorwert zu hoch und dann haben wir gesagt,
ok, jetzt automatischer Abbruch bei dem Test. Dann haben wir das nachher nochmal
feinjustiert, sich angeguckt, die Daten, es gab nicht wirklich ein Problem.
Aber das hat dann schon wieder ein, zwei Monate gedauert, bis man dann sagen
konnte, wir können den Test wiederholen. Das ist ja Raketentechnologie,
da kann man dann nicht sofort am nächsten Tag wieder so eine Stufe dann volltanken.
Und außerdem war das ja auch das Flugmodell. Das war ja nicht so,
dass das ein Testmodell war, sondern das war ja wirklich das,
das Flugmodell von der Rakete, was fliegen sollte.
Also Februar hat nicht funktioniert.
Aber wenn es überhaupt nicht funktioniert, dann hieß es irgendwann mal April.
Und da sah man auch schon, okay, das klappt nicht, das kriegen die in Amerika
nicht hin. Also das Service Modul, muss ich ja sagen, war seit Ende 2018 in
Amerika, ist dann natürlich integriert worden.
Das hat auch mehrere Jahre gedauert, bis das dann komplett durchgetestet und
betankt war. Wir haben betankt Anfang 21, ich glaube im März 21.
Und wir sind dann, ja, das Raumschiff wurde wirklich dann im März 21 betankt
und wir sind Ende 22 geflogen.
Also wir sind anderthalb Jahre quasi betankt am Boden gestanden.
Also von der Raumschlussseite, von Orion her, waren wir fertig.
Wir hätten auch Mitte 21 schon fliegen können.
Aber der SLS hat halt ein bisschen gedauert.
Was macht man denn dann in der Zwischenzeit? Ich meine, Däumchen drehen oder?
Ja, das machen wir bei uns im Projekt garantiert nicht.
Also ich muss sagen, es ist wirklich ein sehr anspruchsvolles Programm,
weil wir ja auch weitere Flugmodelle ausliefern.
Wir haben ja erst im 1. gut geliefert 2018, Aber die formale Qualifikation lief
dann auch bis zum Ende 2020.
Also das hat das ganze Papier. Noch war das, dass die ESA gesagt hat,
okay, das Modul ist für den Nutzen, der angedacht ist, qualifiziert.
Das ist ja wieder Abnahme, soll ich mal. Und dann gab es ja ESM2,
was ja auch schon im Bau befand. ESM3 auch schon. Die Komponenten werden schon
produziert für ESM4, ESM5, ESM6.
Genau, weil das wird ja auch nicht wiederverwendet. Das wurde hochgeflogen und
das tut seinen Dienst. Aber es kehrt ja nicht zurück. Also braucht man für jede
Mission nochmal ein neues Modul.
Richtig. Das ist so. Der Aufwand dieses Systems zu recovern wäre wesentlich
größer und hätte auch einen riesigen Impact auf die Systemarchitektur,
als das jetzt immer wieder neu zu bauen und das dann verglühen zu lassen.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen für mich kein Problem. Manche Leute sagen auch
schade, jetzt habe ich da vier Jahre lang daran gearbeitet an dem Teil und jetzt ist es verglüht.
Ich meine, für mich ist das halt der Zweck. Er wird dafür gebaut,
dass er dann am Ende verglüht. Er hat eine gewisse Lebensdauer,
die Lebensdauer ist dann zu Ende und dann kommt ja schon das Neue.
Service Modul, also das ESM2, haben wir.
Ende 2021 schon nach Florida ausgeliefert.
Und gerade in Bremen sind die schon sehr weit fortgeschritten,
das Service-Modul für Artemis 3 zu integrieren.
Da ist jetzt geplant, dass im Herbst die Auslieferung stattfindet.
Das ist ja dann auch das Service-Modul, das ist ja sehr besonders,
das ist ja das Service-Modul für die eigentliche Mondlandung.
Das steht da jetzt schon sehr weit fortgeschritten rum.
Artemis 2 wird ja gerade getestet in Kennedy. Wir erwarten, dass das komplett
durchgetestet ist im April.
Und dann wird es verbunden mit dem Crew Module für Artemis 2,
wo dann das erste Mal die Astronauten drinfliegen.
Also wirklich eine sehr spannende...
Also Europa ist im Zeitplan, kann man sagen.
Europa ist im Zeitplan. Also wir schlagen uns wirklich sehr gut auch dank Airbus,
die auch immer wieder gucken, wie sie die Planung optimieren können und die
Produktion verbessern können.
Ganz klar. Jetzt bei, das ist je nachdem von der Mission, ob es jetzt Raumschiff
ist oder Launcher, ich denke mal bei Artemis 3, ist es von der Planung her sehr anspruchsvoll.
SpaceX muss natürlich auch erstmal die Landefähre bauen und fliegen.
Bevor sie damit auf den Mond landen können und bis jetzt haben wir natürlich
auch keine Hardware gesehen.
Genau, das ist noch ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik, auch wenn SpaceX ja bisher gezeigt
hat, dass sie ganz gut performen können, wenn es mal drauf ankommt.
Bleiben wir mal bei Artemis 1.
Also Service Modul ist schon lange fertig. Das Problem war am Ende der Launcher,
die SLS, weil man wollte einfach sehr, sehr, sehr vorsichtig sein,
weil zumindest eins ist ja im Prinzip auch der Test sozusagen.
Das ist der erste Flug, wo die Rakete das erste Mal fliegt,
das ist der erste Flug, wo das Service Modul und die neue Orion-Kapsel fliegt
und wo man ja auch einen komplett anderen Anflugsweg geplant hat,
als das jetzt bei den Apollo-Missionen waren, einfach um nochmal Treibstoff auch zu sparen.
Das ist ja so ein ganz pfiffiger Gravity Assist, der dort geflogen wurde.
Ja, das stimmt. Also vielleicht kann ich ja mal durch die Mission durchgehen.
Genau, du wolltest mal jetzt zum Start kommen und dann können wir das ja mal Schritt für Schritt.
Also nachdem wir dann schon im September in Houston waren, wo dann ja zweimal
der Start abgebrochen wurde, aus technischen Gründen, gab es dann ja noch zweimal
eine eine Verzögerung wegen dem Hurricane.
Stimmt. Das heißt, da gab es erstmal den Hurricane, wo wirklich viel Schaden
entstanden ist in Florida, was dann den neuen Starttermin auf den 14.11.
Geschoben hat und dann wirklich Woche vorher kam dann wieder ein Hurricane und
die Rakete stand ja schon draußen in dem Wetter.
Und musste wieder reingeholt werden.
Nein, diesmal beim zweiten Mal ist sie nicht wieder rein geholt wollen die draußen
geblieben. Ja also ich weiß nicht ob es eine Kategorie Kategorie 1 Hurricane
war oder im Endeffekt nur ein tropischer Sturm da gibt es ja dann diese da bin
ich jetzt auch Experte Hurricanes.
Also es war schlechtes Wetter aber es hat ordentlich Es war sicher,
dass es passiert ist. fast wie in Holland heute, nur nicht so warm dabei.
Deswegen wurde der Starttermin von 14. auf den 16.11.
Verschoben, weil dieser Feuer, dieser Hurricane durchlief und die mussten nochmal
den Launcher und das Raumschiff angucken und hätten den 14.11. nicht geschafft.
Naja, und dann, gut, da waren wir halt mit unserem Team, also unser Team war quasi zweigeteilt.
Hier bei ASTEC haben wir einen Raum, wo die Telemetrie ankommt,
wo auch die Daten des Raums schlusslich eingeguckt werden können.
Und wir haben natürlich auch in Houston die Mission unterstützt.
Das heißt, ich war dann zum Beispiel mit einem Kollegen von Airbus in Houston,
aber auch bei allen anderen Subsystemen.
Wir waren ungefähr 20 Leute aus Europa im Kontrollzentrum in Houston,
wo wir dann den Start und den Flug von SLS und Orion verfolgt haben.
Und halt auch während des Fluges haben wir dann mitgeholfen, die Daten auszuwerten,
die Systeme zu monitoren, um einfach zu gucken, ob alles im grünen Bereich ist,
dass es keine Probleme gibt, über die sich Houston Sorgen machen muss.
Naja, und da kann ich gleich noch mal drauf zukommen.
War das eigentlich, ich meine, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das schon für die
amerikanische Seele auch nochmal so ein besonderer Moment war,
der Start dieser Mission, oder?
Ja, selbstverständlich. Also man hat zum Beispiel auch, jetzt hatten wir bei
Artemis, bei dem Launch am 16. auch einen Nachtlaunch.
Da war in Kennedy jetzt nicht so ganz viel los, aber beim ersten Ansatz,
Ende August, da ja hunderttausende Menschen in Florida.
Kamala Harris als Vice-President war vor Ort, da wurde die Nationalhymne gesungen,
da gab es Flyby's, das war richtig ein Event.
Also ich habe auch viele Bekannte in Amerika und das haben die in den Medien
mitbekommen, die haben sich darauf gefreut, dass das stattfindet.
Das war schon ein bisschen anders als in Europa, also in Europa war das natürlich
auch in den Medien, aber das ist natürlich auch ein nationales,
stolzes, nationales Projekt und Mission, wo wir als Europa...
Und das möchte ich noch mal hier auch feststellen, als Juniorpartner mit dabei
sind, aber wir sind da als Partner mit dabei.
Unsere Industrie und auch die ESA sind halt in der Lage heutzutage,
so ein Modul zu liefern und bei einer Mondmission mit dabei zu sein.
Das muss man sich mal auch auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Wenn man sagen würde,
okay, wir hätten in den 60ern oder in den 60ern schon da mitgemacht bei so einer Mission wie Apollo.
Das wäre natürlich Wahnsinn gewesen. Und jetzt sind wir halt in der Lage dazu, das zu tun.
Und das ist auch für uns im Projektteam, aber auch für die Leute,
die Raumfahrt interessiert sind in Europa natürlich was ganz Spezielles, denke ich.
Ja, kann ich an der Stelle nochmal auf Raumzeit Nummer 98 verweisen.
Da habe ich nämlich mit Helmut Trischler mal die Geschichte der europäischen
Raumfahrt aufgemacht, also speziell natürlich dann auch die der ESA.
Und das ist schon bemerkenswert, welchen Weg man genommen hat,
weil zu Apollo-Zeiten war natürlich hier mit europäischer Raumfahrt noch nichts zu sehen.
Ja, soweit ich weiß, war hier eine Kuhwiese, wo wir heute sitzen.
Das war in den 60ern war hier nicht, da war Sumpf.
Aber jetzt auch so in Houston im Kontrollzentrum, ist das dann alles überlagert
von der Wichtigkeit der eigenen Arbeit in dem Moment oder hat man das irgendwie
auch schon gemerkt, dass da so eine gewisse Emotionalität sich breit gemacht hat?
In Houston ist das so aufgebaut, also wir haben das in einem Kontrollzentrum
haben wir den Control Room, da sitzen dann diese Flycontroller,
was quasi unser Darmstadt ist, also wir haben bei der ESA ja auch ein Kontrollzentrum in Darmstadt.
Das sind die Leute, die wirklich auch die Kommandos an das Raumschiff schicken
dürfen und das dann fliegen dementsprechend.
Und wir zusammen mit den amerikanischen Ingenieursteams saßen in der Mission
Evaluation Room, wo quasi viel Telemetrie reinkommt, wo man sich wirklich die
Details von den Systemen anguckt.
Aber wir haben im Endeffekt die gleichen Displays wie die Flugcontroller zur
Verfügung und wir haben uns das genauso angeguckt wie die auch.
Bildschirme, kann man sich ja dann so vorstellen.
Für die Amerikaner war das ein sehr wichtiges Programm, weil da jährlich Milliarden
in das Projekt gesteckt wurden.
Es gab auch viele Stimmen, die sagten, das ist ein Dinosaurierprojekt,
das alte Technologien mit alten Industrien verwendet.
Warum nehmen wir nicht einfach SpaceX oder Blue Origin und machen da alles mit?
Dass die NASA nur noch Verträge rausgibt für den Service und nicht mehr so wie
jetzt an der Entwicklung tief beteiligt ist.
Aber Gott sei Dank hat ja alles sehr gut funktioniert bei Artemis I und ich
glaube, diese Stimmen sind jetzt so ein bisschen, merkt man auch,
auf Twitter und so ein bisschen ruhiger geworden, weil natürlich jetzt ein Erfolg da ist.
Das Programm ist immer noch teuer und bewegt sich manchmal auch ein bisschen
schwerfällig, aber man hat eine erfolgreiche Mission zum Mond geflogen.
Und das wäre jetzt auch wirklich schlimm gewesen, wenn das gescheitert wäre.
Ja, das wäre...
Also, man weiß nicht... Es ist immer schlimm, wenn was scheitert,
aber ich glaube, das wäre dann schon wirklich sehr bedrohlich geworden für die NASA.
Ich denke auch.
Generell, wahrscheinlich hätte man dann den Ansatz der Großprojekte der NASA
vielleicht in Frage gestellt.
Also, wenn das dann vor 20 Jahren passiert wäre, gab es ja keine Alternative.
Aber jetzt gibt es halt in der Privatindustrie durchaus Kompetenzen und andere
Herangehensweise an Raumfahrtprogramme, wo man vielleicht schneller und besser dabei ist.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist das ja auch ein so komplexes und spezielles System.
Und die NASA hat natürlich jahrzehntelange Erfahrungen auf dem Gebiet auch,
muss man sagen, die natürlich auch nützlich ist und man auch nicht vernachlässigen
darf. Man darf jetzt nicht sagen, warum geben wir das nicht alles an die private Industrie.
Der Ansatz der ESA ist ja immer ein bisschen, wir sind ja ein bisschen mehr
als Agentur, als Procurement Agency da im Vergleich zu NASA.
Die NASA hat ja wirklich eine Abteilung, wo entwickelt wird und das dann quasi
der D-Industrie vorgegeben wird.
Das ist noch ein bisschen anders hier bei der ESA. Wir sind noch ein bisschen
leaner als die NASA. Also ich sag mal im Vergleich, es sind dreimal so viele
Leute von der NASA an dem ESM-Projekt, beschäftigt als wie bei der ESA.
Wirklich?
Ja, das ist halt so. die sind da sehr viel.
Da sind wir halt sehr lean. Wir arbeiten quasi unter einem sehr großen Pensum,
um das alles zu verfolgen und von unserer Seite her zu shapeen.
Nicht schlecht. Kommen wir zurück zum Start. Du warst in Houston,
oder nicht? Genau. Wir sind jetzt alle mal in Houston.
Gewisse Nervosität macht sich breit, aber ich bin mir sicher,
dass es total überlagert von der üblichen Professionalität, die die Leute in
dem Moment an den Tag legen. Der Start gelingt am 16.11.
Das Ding boostet halt irgendwie los und wenn die SLS sozusagen ihre Aufgabe
erfüllt hat, gibt es eine Trennung.
Das heißt, ab dem Moment übernimmt auch das Service-Modul den Antrieb.
Oder gab es noch eine zweite Stufe? Nein, gab es nicht.
Es gab eine Oberstufe bei der Rakete. Das heißt, man hat diese Translunar Injection Eyes.
Das ist quasi das Manöver, was von der Oberstufe durchgeführt wird.
Also die Oberstufe mit Orion trennt sich vom SLS und macht dann einen großen
Boost, um das Raumschiff Richtung Mond zu schicken.
Und wie genau war die Injektion an der Stelle? Ist die gut gelaufen?
Die ist sowohl, also gerade der Booster hat, also Booster SLS hat sehr gut funktioniert.
Die Oberstufe auch präzise auf die Flugbange kommen zum Mond und dann findet diese Trennung statt.
Das ist nach ungefähr zwei Stunden, glaube ich, findet die Trennung statt,
zwei Stunden nach dem Start.
Und dann übernimmt quasi das Raumschiff und das Servicemodul.
Zwei Stunden, das war echt krass viel.
Ja, gut, man startet halt erstmal, macht dann sozusagen eine Umrundung fast
um die Erde, Da sind ja schon mal so ungefähr 90 Minuten, dann wartet man kurz
und dann findet das Manöver statt, um vom Erdorbit rauszukommen Richtung Umrund.
Also um erst mal sozusagen den richtigen Punkt zu finden, wo man dann los kann.
Wo man dann los kann, genau. Weil das hängt dann immer davon ab,
wann man jetzt genau starten... Im Idealfall startet man ja genau so,
dass man gar nicht erst nochmal umrunden lässt, oder?
Nein, eigentlich ist das so geplant, dass man nicht direkt da jetzt...
Man hat ja gewisse Orbitmechaniken um die Erden drum herum, die man nicht jetzt
einfach so übergehen kann.
Ja, ich wollte auch nichts übergehen. Ich frage mich nur, warum man nicht einfach
direkt den richtigen Punkt finden kann. Was wird durch diese zusätzliche Umrundung noch gewonnen?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Entweder ist das wirklich so ein Sicherheitsaspekt.
Ich bin jetzt kein Orbitmechaniker, aber entweder ist das jetzt ein Sicherheitsaspekt,
um erstmal einen stabilen Erdorbett zu haben. Man ist ja nie richtig einmal
rum, man fliegt da quasi so dreiviertel rum.
Und wenn dann was schief gehen würde, würde man erstmal noch mal im Erdorben bleiben.
Wenn dieses CLA nicht funktionieren würde aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Diese Translunar Injection.
So, also die SLS hat dann quasi ihre Schuldigkeit getan. Die Oberstufe ist dann auch fertig.
Trennt jetzt Orion ab. Und Orion besteht eben aus dem Service-Modul und aus dem Crew-Modul.
Und das zusammen ist jetzt auf einer Trajektorie Richtung Mond.
Richtig.
Und diesmal hat man aber den Mond ziemlich scharf angeschnitten, sozusagen,
indem man – also man muss sich ja immer klarmachen,
so, Mond dreht sich halt langsam um die Erde,
braucht ja einen Monat, aber man kommt jetzt sozusagen nicht von hinten und bremst dann ab,
sondern man kommt sozusagen von vorne, macht so eine halbe Umrundung um den
Mond, fliegt sozusagen der Mond dem Mondorbit entgegen und lässt sich dann vom Mond abbremsen.
Das ist ja sozusagen so ein bisschen das Gegenteil, was man eigentlich normalerweise
so kennt. Oft werden ja Planeten, also alle Körper mit ausreichend Masse,
werden ja in der Regel zur Beschleunigung benutzt, aber genauso kann man das ja auch zum abbremsen.
Ja, sicher, also hier, man muss sich das ja so vorstellen, wenn man in der Mitte,
wenn man jetzt nicht so diese Konstellation vorstellt, in der Mitte ist die
Erde und da dreht sich der Mond drumherum. Einmal wie du es richtig gesagt hast,
das dauert halt einen Monat, bis der Mond einmal rum ist.
Und das Raumschiff rein sollte jetzt in diesen Distant Retrograde Orbit.
Wenn man sich eine Skizze anguckt von dieser Mission, sieht das immer aus wie
ein Kreis um den Mond. Aber im Im Endeffekt was es ist, ist,
dass das Raumschiff auch...
In eine Umlaufbahn um die Erde fliegt.
Diese Outbound Powered Fly, weil das ist das erste große Manöver,
was von dem Service-Modul durchgeführt wird, das lenkt das Raumschiff nah am
Mond, und der Mond nimmt dann das Raumschiff mit.
Dadurch wird das Raumschiff durch die Schwerkraft vom Mond in diesen Distant
Retrograde Orbit geflogen. Das ist natürlich noch ein bisschen komplizierter
von der Bahnmechanik her.
Aber ich fliege dann erstmal mit dem Mond mit und verändere dann meinen Abstand
und dadurch sieht das dann nachher aus, als ob ich da einen Kreis drum fliege.
Und dann, also dieser Transfer von der Erde bis zum Mond hat jetzt 6 Tage gedauert ungefähr.
Und dann wurde dieses Outbound Powered Flyby, da war man glaube ich auf 160
Kilometer Höhen, also sehr nah wirklich an der Mondoberfläche.
Und wurde dann quasi mitgenommen in diesen Distant Retrograde Overt,
wo man dann auch so um die sechs, sieben Tage geblieben ist und dann hat man
dieses Return Powered Flyby Manöver geflogen.
Das heißt im Endeffekt dadurch dann wieder durch die Mondschwerkraft Richtung Erde katapultiert.
Also man nutzt sozusagen die Schwerkraft des Mondes zweimal aus,
das Ganze wird aber auch nochmal von so einem Burn begleitet.
Ja genau. das mal angeschaut. Das ist wirklich ganz interessant,
weil du sagst, es hängt immer so ein bisschen davon ab, von welchem Körper aus
schaut man sich jetzt eben diese Bahn an.
Aus Sicht des Mondes ist es halt so, da kommt eben dieser Körper angeschossen,
fliegt sehr nah an ihm vorbei, bremst selber noch mal ein bisschen ab,
aber im Wesentlichen ist es halt die Anziehungskraft des Mondes,
die das Raumfahrzeug abbremst.
Daraus ergibt sich so ein elliptischer orbit um den um den mond herum und wenn
man das zweite mal am mond vorbeikommt.
Bremst man schon wieder beschleunigt und zurückgeflogen. Wenn man das ganze
von der Erde aus betrachtet, macht das Raumfahrzeug eigentlich nur eine große Ellipse wieder zurück.
Da gibt es tolle Animationen auch bei uns auf unserer Webseite.
In diesen zwei verschiedenen Reference Frames, in diesen Bezugsfenstern.
Also wenn man da jetzt drauf guckt und im erdfesten Koordinatensystem,
wo man dann sagt, der Mond dreht sich immer so mit und man guckt sich dann an,
wie sich dann relativ dazu das Raumschiff bewegt, dann ist das quasi eine Ellipse
dahin und dann halt so ein Kreis um den Mond rum und dann wieder eine Ellipse zurück.
Wenn man sich jetzt anguckt, dass die Erde sich quasi im Mittelpunkt ist und
der Mond dreht sich um die Erde in diesem Koordinatensystem,
dann fliegt das Raumschiff quasi mit dem Mond mit, mit einem gewissen und variierenden Abstand.
Aber das ist ja dann auch in der Realität so, auch wenn ich im wirklichen Mondorbit
bin, dann bin ich ja auch um den Mond rum und fliege da mit dem Mond mit.
Relativ gesehen zur Erde bewege ich mich dann eher so wie der Mond.
Das ist natürlich auch das Antriebsvermögen vom Orion, das ist geringer als
bei Apollo, weil Apollo hat ja diesen Einschuss in den lower lunar orbit gemacht.
Da braucht man halt ein bisschen mehr Antriebsvermögen für.
Hier hat das System halt ein bisschen weniger Antriebsvermögen und dadurch können
dann solche Manöver durchgeführt werden, also mit diesem Powered Flyby und so
weiter. wo man halt dann die Schwerkraft des Mondes benutzt,
um eine Geschwindigkeitsänderung an dem Raumschiff durchzuführen.
So, wie sah das jetzt aus der technischen Begleitung aus?
Ihr wart da jetzt sozusagen in Newston und jetzt ging es ja leider drum.
Also du warst dann auch die ganzen Zeitraum über in Newston.
Ja, stimmt. Missionsverlauf. Was hat denn jetzt funktioniert und was hat denn nicht funktioniert?
Weil irgendwas funktioniert ja immer nicht. Ich erzähle dir,
dass jetzt alles problemlos funktioniert hat.
Also, ich muss sagen, man kennt ja auch seine, ich spreche jetzt vom Antriebssystem,
man kennt ja auch seine Schwachstellen im System bzw.
Nicht unbedingt Schwachstellen, sondern vielleicht die Komponenten oder die
Subsysteme, die so ein bisschen einem während der Entwicklung Kopfzerbrechen
bereitet haben. Da denkt man, oh Gott, hoffentlich klappt das alles.
Im Antriebssystem hat wirklich alles super funktioniert. Es gab im Interview,
da gab es alle paar Tage Interview mit den NASA-Projektleitern,
da fragte ein Reporter auch, welcher Schulnummer würden sie dem Antriebssystem
geben, und der Flight Director aus dem Kontrollzimmer hat gesagt,
straight A, also halt eine Glatte 1.
Das war natürlich sehr gut für uns und vor allen Dingen die Kollegen in Bremen,
die das System ja im Wesentlichen entworfen und gebaut haben,
dass das so gut funktioniert alles.
Es gibt natürlich immer so kleine Abweichungen. Ich will es nicht mal als Anomalie
bezeichnen, weil gut, man fliegt das zum ersten Mal, das ist ein paar Sachen, paar Daten oder...
Das Verhalten vom System mal ein bisschen anders ist, wie man es ausgelegt hat.
Das ist, glaube ich, normal.
Anomalie heißt ja auch nur, irgendein Grenzwert wird überschritten,
den man eigentlich nicht überschritten haben wollte.
Ja, oder man hat wirklich auch operationelle Probleme. Klar,
wir haben viele Anomalien aufgeschrieben, weil du sagst, es wurde ein Grenzwert überschritten.
Formal war es eine Anomalie, aber es hatte einfach technisch keinen Einfluss aufs System.
Es gab auch, und das wurde auch in der Presse gesagt,
bei uns im Power Subsystem, Da gibt es diese Power Conditioning and Distribution
Unit, also diese Elektronikbox, die den Strom von den Solarpanelen kriegt,
Load Current Limiters, also so eine Art Sicherung, die da eingebaut sind.
Die sind hin und wieder mal rausgeflogen und wir wussten nicht so richtig, warum.
Aber das ist dann wie zu Hause, man kann die dann wieder reinklicken über einen
Befehl und dann läuft das wieder ein paar Tage und dann ist sie mal wieder rausgeflogen.
Das heißt, es war jetzt keine permanente Degradation von dem System.
Das ist eine der Sachen gewesen, die den Leuten im Baubereich ein bisschen Kopfzerbrechen bereitet haben.
Aber nicht wirklich, dass man sagen würde, wir haben jetzt Redundanz verloren.
Wir wissen, dass es ein wiederkehrendes Problem ist, was jetzt für AtomS2 behoben
wird. Da sind wir jetzt schon dran.
Aber also wirklich, also vom...
Crew-Modul, vom Service-Modul lief alles wirklich sehr, sehr gut.
Also ich selbst überrascht, also persönlich muss ich sagen mit der Vorgeschichte.
Lief denn auch alles automatisch ab oder musste man auch jetzt sozusagen manuell
noch irgendwas freischalten? Oder war das im Prinzip alles vorbestimmt?
Im Prinzip ist das alles vorgeplant vor allen Dingen, also sequenziert und dann
halt auch teilweise kontrolliert von der Software, also Close Loop.
Das heißt, manche Sachen, da kann man natürlich vom Boden her einflussnehmen,
muss man aber nicht unbedingt.
Das läuft dann automatisch durch. Ich kann zum Beispiel sagen,
diese großen Manöver beim Outbound Power Flyby und beim Return Power Flyby Manöver,
das sind wirklich, wo das Haupttriebwerk zwei Minuten brennt,
beziehungsweise drei Minuten, also ein großes Manöver, wenn man denkt,
dass eine Gesamtbrenndauer von dem System vielleicht zwölf Minuten sein kann.
Das wird hinter dem Mond ausgeführt, ohne Kommunikation mit der Erde.
Also komplett autonom. Man fliegt da halt rein, dann schalten die ganzen Anzeigen
auf Türkis, weil das ist die Anzeige, wenn keine Daten kommen.
Und dann holt man sich erstmal Kaffee.
Weil man kann nichts machen.
Man kann nur warten, weil man kann ja auch keine Kommandos entschicken.
Und zu sehen gibt es auch nichts. Also es ist alles komplett im Funsch,
man hat überhaupt keine Möglichkeit. Man bräuchte halt irgendein Relay,
der noch mit rumfliegt, aber der existiert nicht.
Den gibt es nicht. Da gibt es wohl jetzt auch eine Idee hier bei der ESA,
das glaube ich Moonlight, zusammen mit Kommunikationsdirektorat und human spaceflight hier,
dass man da Satelliten in den Mondorbit oder in DRO setzt, mit dem man dann
Relay machen kann zurück zur Erde. DRO ist?
Wo dann zum Beispiel auch der Gateway die Gateway Station sein wird.
NAHO glaube ich. NAHO ist es, wo der Gateway sein wird. Aber gibt's,
nicht.
Gibt es derzeit noch nicht.
Gibt es derzeit noch nicht, deswegen auch nicht unbedingt relevant.
Also muss man warten und das ist klar, da muss halt alles automatisch ausgeführt
werden. Das heißt, all diese ganzen, sowohl das Abrämsmanöver als auch das Beschleunigungsmanöver,
fällt da, glaube ich, darunter?
Genau, im Endeffekt waren es die beiden.
Also das Wichtigste sozusagen findet statt und man darf noch nicht mal live zuschauen.
Deswegen kannst du ja vorstellen, dass ich bei dem ersten Manöver leicht nervös
war, Also generell, es gab so ein paar Punkte. Also Band war halt der Aufstieg,
also der Start der Rakete, weil da wirklich viele Sachen im System,
das ist alles sequenziert und muss auf die Sekunde genau passieren.
Haltest du auf die Millisekunde genau, oder?
Ja, also genau, es ist in Millisekunden im Endeffekt spezifiziert, ja.
Richtig, also man hat dann gewisse Zeitvorgaben, in denen Sachen passieren müssen,
und dann quetscht man da seine Operationen rein.
Und es fing ja an auch mit dem Tanken und so, das ist ja alles von Countdown
geht glaube ich bei minus 42 Stunden los.
Ja und ich bin dann halt ins Kontrollzentrum gegangen bei T-6 Stunden.
Und dann sieht man halt wie das Bild getankt wird, wie es dann nicht klappt
und wie es dann wieder klappt und so weiter. Also das ist dann schon alles ziemlich
hektisch und ich gerne auch mal eine kleine Anekdote vielleicht zum Besten geben.
Ich saß dann an der Propulsion-Konsole in diesem Mission Evaluation-Raum und
neben mir waren die Leute, die Mechaniker, also Loads und so was machen,
also die Mechanical Engineers, sag ich mal.
Und da war ja dieser Hurricane durchgeflogen und dann sind da auch an der Kapsel
so ein bisschen dichtmaterial abgegangen, was die vorher schon gesehen hatten.
Dann hatten die auch wieder ein Problem mit dem Betanken. Da mussten die so
eine Crew rausschicken, die dann live mit einem halbgefüllten Rakete oben drüber
unten im Groundsystem nochmal wieder ein paar Flansche anziehen mussten und
ein paar Muttern, damit das dicht wurde.
Das war wirklich interessant. Das hieß Red Team. Interessanterweise kamen die
alle in blauen Overrolls raus. Da wusste auch keiner, warum die jetzt Red Team heißen.
Auf jeden Fall war das auch sehr lustig. Da hat man gesehen,
wir sind eigentlich gut im Zeitplan, aber wir haben ja nur zwei Stunden Startfenster.
Das heißt, wenn sich da im Betanken oder in der Sequenz vorher was bestätigt,
man muss anhalten, man muss Sachen überprüfen, man muss Sachen reparieren.
Wie gesagt, der Flansch musste angezogen werden, damit der Wasserstoff nicht
mehr rausleckte. Das war halt in Kennedy alles und wir sehen das okay.
Die Jungs vom Red Team kamen und dann guckten die in die Kameras und hängten da oben drin rum.
Dann hatten die noch mehr von diesem Lichtmaterial gesehen, was halt während
dem Hurricane so ein bisschen losgegangen war, dass das baumelte da so rum.
Das hatten die wohl bei der Begehung ein paar Tage vorher noch nicht festgestellt.
Der Kollege neben mir, der musste dann halt quasi aus dem Bildmaterial Größe,
Volumen, bestimmen und was passieren könnte, wenn das abfällt.
Ob das irgendwie ein Problem ist. Man hat ja beim Challenger...
Bei der Katastrophe war ja genau das Problem.
Genau, dass halt der Wasserstoss, der Material abgegangen ist und auf die Flügelvorderkanten
von dem Shuttle gefallen ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt die gleiche Besorgnis war.
Auf jeden Fall war das noch ein Problem, was sich noch angeguckt werden muss
und was halt für den Staat wirklich auch bereinigt muss. Da musst du ja sagen,
wenn ja geht oder ja geht nicht. Und dann kam irgendwann die Durchsage über uns zumindest. Yes.
So, Loads, wie sieht es aus? Red Team ist fertig. Wir warten noch auf deine
Freigabe für den Start. Der Typ, der hat natürlich auch ein Backoffice gehabt,
wo die das dann organisiert haben und so weiter.
Und spitzen. Der saß direkt neben mir.
Ja und dann irgendwann, Gott sei Dank, also dreiviertel Stunde vor dem wirklichen
Start an, sagte, okay, we're clear. Alle im Zimmer.
Erstmal alle erleichtert, und dann ging es ja wieder in den Countdown.
Das war wirklich eine spannende Angelegenheit.
Und dann Countdown, T-minus eine Minute. Das war schon mal weiter als letztes
Mal, das ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht.
Mal gucken, was noch passiert. Team minus 10 seconds. Also, shit.
Geht's jetzt wirklich los?
Ich sag's erst einmal, wir sitzen immer mit NASA-Kollegen an den Konsolen.
Geht jetzt echt los. Scheiße, geht echt los.
Ja, und dann ging es halt los. Und dann ist das ja wirklich wie ein Film.
Wir haben das vorher auch sehr oft trainiert. Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so,
dass wir da hingehen und machen das das erste Mal. Wir haben ja hier diesen
Telemetrieraum, wo wir das simulieren können. Wir waren auch öfter in Houston
vorher, um in den Raum immer Flugsimulationen zu machen.
Also wirklich vergleichbar wie ein Pilot, der für einen gewissen Flieger trainieren
muss. Haben wir halt für die Mission trainiert und dann auch ganz oft Aufstieg.
Und dann lief das halt wirklich wie im Simulator. Da gab es ein paar kleine
Punkte, wo mir mal das Herz hingewiesen ist, weil das dann doch nicht alles so ist wie im Simulator.
Da hatte die Software mal was Komisches angezeigt von den Ventilen.
Ich dachte, shit, jetzt müssen wir hier eine Contingency-Procedure und so ablaufen
lassen. War aber Gott sei Dank nur, sag ich mal, eine Software-Sache.
Also physikalisch hatte das keinen Grund, Gott sei Dank. Also da gab es keine Probleme.
Dann war unser System fertig. Wir waren quasi startklar.
Wie du sagtest, man merkt es knistert in der Luft, aber es ist professionelle
Anspannung. Es ist jetzt nicht
so, dass da die Leute irgendwie austicken oder dass viel Quatsch wird.
Aber beim Outbound Powered Fly, das war ungefähr nach sechs Tagen nach dem Start,
da hat man gemerkt, okay, die Systeme funktionieren alle ganz gut.
Man hat gesehen, unser Power-Subsystem liefert super. Also mehr Strom als gedacht.
Unser Thermalsystem braucht nicht so viel Strom, weil die Sachen nicht so kalt
werden wie gedacht. Das geht ja noch ein paar Grad, aber trotzdem, das ist halt Leistung.
Also die Heizung ist im Prinzip nur ein Radiator letztlich, oder?
Ja gut, das sind halt viele Heizer, so Heizfolien mit Temperaturfühlern immer
daneben, um zu gucken, dass das auch richtig auf die richtige Temperatur gesetzt wird.
Das ist halt das, Das ist das passive Thermalkontrollsystem,
was über elektrische Leistung heizt.
Wenn es dann nicht mehr benötigt wird, geht es aus und wenn es wieder benötigt wird, geht es an.
Dann gibt es dieses aktive Thermalkontrollsystem, wo dann diese Radiatoren außen
sind und eine Kühlflüssigkeit durch das System gepumpt wird.
Da werden dann verschiedene Baugruppen, die Wärme absondern.
Mit versorgt und gekühlt. Und nachher auch die Kapsel damit auch gekühlt bzw.
Beheizt. Thermalsystem heißt also sowohl für die ganze Technik,
für die Gase etc. aber eben auch für das Chromodul.
Das ist das aktive Thermalkontroll.
Und das wurde im Prinzip auch schon auf Menschenbedarf hingeheizt.
Richtig, also die Kapsel war auf Temperatur.
Aber da waren jetzt keine Dummies an Bord.
Doch, da waren drei Dummies an Bord. Die Nase hatte eine Puppe.
So eine Ganzkörperpuppe, die hatte irgendwie einen Commander,
Commander Munikin oder so hieß sie.
Und die hat auch selber Wärme erzeugt?
Nein, ich glaube nicht. Nee? Nein, nein. Ich glaube nicht. Und dann waren noch
zwei Puppen, also eine vom DLR. Das war so eine Half-Body-Puppe.
Und das war eine Kooperation, die das DLR wohl mit den Israelis hatten.
Da gab es zwei Puppen. Eine Puppe war eine normale mit ganz vielen Sensoren
ausgestattet und die andere hatte dann so eine Strahlungsweste an.
Mit den gleichen Sensoren ausgestattet, dann sollte gezeigt werden,
was passiert, wenn wir so eine Mission fliegen, wie viel Strahlung kommt da
eigentlich an, wie schlecht ist das für die Astronauten, hilft so eine Weste.
Dann waren noch zwei Tiere an Bord. Snoopy?
Und Sean das Schaf.
Aber kein wirkliches Schaf.
Nein, nein, also dieser Cartoon-Charakter, das war halt unser ESA-Maskottchen,
was mitgeflogen ist. Und dann Snoopy, das was ja seit der Apollo-Zeiten das
Maskottchen der NASA für die Bermannter Raumfahrt ist. Der war dann in einem Raumanzug mit.
Und nochmal dann zurückzukommen auf diesen Return- oder Outbound-Powered-Fly-By,
wo das Manöver hinter dem Mond, im Funkloch sozusagen, durchgeführt wurde.
Das war interessant, weil das war für mich das erste Mal, dass das passiert.
Ich war total aufgeregt und so weiter. Ich hoffe, das klappt und ich komme wieder raus.
Bis dann irgendwann die Fly-Controller mit dem Kaffee bei uns in diese Mission
Evaluation Room reinkommen und anfangen zu quatschen.
Und alle stehen und quatschen und denken so, okay, anscheinend...
Anscheinend läuft es gut. Und dann kriegt man dann eine Anzeige,
natürlich, AOS Acquisition of Signer.
Das ist natürlich alles geplant, man weiß ja ungefähr, wann dann wieder Sichtbarkeit da zur Erde,
also eine Line of Sight zur Bodenstation besteht und dann weiß man ungefähr,
ok so und so viele Sekunden bis wir unser Telemetrieset wieder haben und ja
dann läuft die Uhr auf Null runter und dann guckt man auf sein,
also bis die Acquisition auf Signal ist und dann kommen halt so langsam die Daten rein.
Also dann werden halt diese Türkisen ziffern, die halt auf dem Display sagen,
ok ich hab keine Telemetrie werden, wie normal. Und man sieht,
dass da wieder was kommt zum Raumschiff.
Und dann plötzlich, Brendauer vom Haupttriebwerk war genau die zwei Minuten
zehn hochgegangen, wussten wir, manöver hat geklappt.
Raumschiff war nicht explodiert, weil wir kriegten ja Daten.
Also alle happy. Man hat sich danach die Bedrückungsarchitektur bei uns im System geguckt.
Sah gut aus, ist so gelaufen. Dann kamen so langsam auch die ganzen Druckdaten
und so weiter rein, wo man ein bisschen Historie braucht und dann konnte man
sagen, okay, wow, hat ja geklappt.
Ist man da eigentlich so auf 24-7 abruf?
Wie macht ihr das? Ihr müsst ja auch mal schlafen. Teilt ihr euch dann im Team
auf, dass immer jemand da ist oder sagt man einfach so, naja,
jetzt darf man mal so gut schlafen und wenn was ist, wird man geweckt?
Schlaf war so eine Sache, kannst du dir vielleicht vorstellen.
Also wir hatten halt wie gesagt ein Team in Houston und ein Team aber auch hier
bei ASTEC, was auch die gleichen Telemetrie hatten.
Wir hatten das so gemacht, pro Konsole hatten wir eigentlich zwei Personen,
die Systemleute hatten ein paar mehr.
Die Systemleute sind halt die, die den Gesamtüberblick über das Gesamtsystem
haben und die wollten halt quasi rund um die Uhr Support machen,
brauchten ein bisschen mehr Leute.
Ich habe mir da mit einem Kollegen quasi die Früh- und die Spätschicht geteilt,
wir haben aber selten Nachtschicht gemacht, nur wenn wirklich was los war.
Also wir haben am Schichtmodus gearbeitet.
Oder zwölf.
Wie nötig, ne? Also offiziell an der Konsole glaube ich zehn mit Handover vorher und nachher.
Und dann natürlich wenn irgendwelche Sachen waren, noch mal vorher und nachher.
Also das ist wirklich nicht zu unterschätzen, weil die Mission ist ja wirklich 24 Stunden.
Das heißt man wird wach, man hat neue Sachen, man vor dem Bett gehen,
gibt es wieder, ist noch was los ist.
Gott sei Dank hatten wir natürlich hier aus Holland guten Support,
weil unser Antriebssystem das größte Subsystem war.
Das gab es auch am meisten zu tun. Wir hatten hier drei Ingenieure,
zwei von der ESA, ein Kollege von Airbus, die dann hier 24-7 rotiert sind.
Das heißt, wir hatten eigentlich immer jemanden vom Antriebssystem,
der live war, meistens zwei.
Man hat offiziell einen Tag Rest bekommen, also Ruhetag bekommen,
aber so viel Ruhe war dann auch nicht. Das kann man sich ja vorstellen,
das ist ja klar, das läuft ja auch dann.
Fährt man dann hier eigentlich nach Hause oder gibt es dann für solche Einsätze
auch hier die Möglichkeit zu schlafen?
Nö, man fährt dann nach Hause oder ins Hotel hier. Genauso wie bei mir in Houston
natürlich auch. Ich bin dann ins Hotel gefahren danach, nach der Schicht.
Das waren ja fast fünf Wochen, wo wir da waren. Das war natürlich eine lange
Zeit. Gott sei Dank ist die nächste Mission zwei Wochen lang nur. Das reicht dann auch.
Und hier also wirklich war auch eine sehr gute Zusammenarbeit zwischen den ungefähr
auch 20 Leuten hier, die hier auch rund um die Uhr gearbeitet haben und in den Houston.
Super Kooperation muss ich sagen zwischen NASA und uns. War auch das erste Mal,
dass wir die Ops dann die Operations dann mit der NASA zusammen durchführen.
Ich meine, die Leute, mit denen wir dann wirklich da zusammengearbeitet haben,
die kannten wir natürlich aus dem Projekt selber.
Die Flight Controller, da hatten wir so ein bisschen weniger Kontakt mit von
hier, weil das sind ja wirklich die, die das fliegen.
Die sind halt nicht unbedingt in der Wickelung so tief.
Beteiligt. Die kriegen quasi das Design und die Capabilities und implementieren dann quasi die Mission.
Auch wenn man ein Auto kriegt, da hat man dann ein Handbuch dazu und dann fährt
man das. Aber man ist ja nicht an der Entwicklung beteiligt unbedingt.
Und dann lief es auch wirklich so gut auch bei den meisten anderen Systemen,
dass dann Management irgendwann gesagt hat, hey, ihr habt alle gedacht,
im Mondorbit ist ruhig, weil da im Endeffekt fliegt man dann nur nebenher und
da ist wirklich wenig los, lasst uns doch mal ein paar neue Tests definieren on orbit.
Und dann haben wir uns hingesetzt und haben uns überlegt, was kann man denn
eigentlich noch so testen.
Es gab halt vordefinierte Test-Objectives, aber auch Sachen,
die jetzt noch mehr gemacht werden konnten.
Es war ja eine Qualifizierungsmission, eine Testmission und dementsprechend
gab es auch schon vorher Sachen, die getestet werden sollen,
die man in einer Mission, die man das nicht unbedingt macht.
Aber wir haben dann noch darüber hinaus neue Sachen on the fly definiert.
Zum Beispiel einen 100-Sekunden-Test mit den Hilfstriebwerken,
der überhaupt nicht vorgesehen war. Da muss halt der Orbit ein bisschen angepasst werden.
Deswegen, um das thermische Verhalten von zwei Triebwerken nebeneinander sich
anzugucken. Da hat man am Boden keine Daten, die haben wir dann quasi on Orbit
gekriegt oder wir haben einen Leckagetest gemacht von Ventilen in Orbit.
Macht man auch nicht für Astronauten.
Was heißt, wie macht man einen Leckagetest?
Man stellt eine gewisse Drucksituation an dem Ventil ein, also vor dem Ventil
einen gewissen Druck und nach dem Ventil hat man einen gewissen Druck.
Und wenn sich diese Drücke ändern, dann leckt es.
Das ist im Endeffekt der relativ einfache.
Und ihr habt das jetzt so weit getrieben, dass es lag oder ihr habt nur geguckt, dass es nicht lag?
Wir haben mal geguckt, ob es lag oder nicht. Im Endeffekt war es wichtig,
um zu gucken, ob sich da irgendwas verändert hat in dem System.
Aber auch für mich wichtig zu wissen, wenn wir mal wirklich ein Problem damit
haben, können wir das dann am Orbit dann irgendwie quantifizieren.
Ja, und noch verschiedene kleinere Tests. Also da wurde eigentlich wirklich
viel auf einmal getestet.
Dann haben die die Triebwerke anders gefeuert. Also es war wirklich auf der
einen Seite ein bisschen spannend, auf der anderen Seite aber auch cool,
dass wir das machen konnten.
So ein bisschen Spielplatz, ne? Ja, genau. Wenn man so einen Raumschiff mit
der Entwicklung Orion, wahrscheinlich 25 Milliarden oder so was,
dann im Mondorbit hat und die Chefs sagen, ja denkt euch mal ein paar Tests
aus. Ja, denk mal, ja. Playground für Grown-ups.
Kommen wir nochmal zum Schluss vielleicht dieser Mission, also Rückkehr.
Also man ist halt einmal hin, einmal um den Mond herum und wieder zurück.
Und ja, dann kommt es ja dann nochmal die Separation, wo dann die eigentliche
Crew, das Crewmodul abgespalten wird und das Servicemodul dann verglüht.
Wann findet das genau statt? Wie kurz vor Landung?
Das ist glaube ich 40 Minuten.
Versuchen wir mal. Zap. Entry Interface. Ich glaube.
Crew ist in Ordnung.
Ich sag mal jetzt 40 Minuten, weil ich habe in weder 40 Minuten noch eine Stunde im Kopf.
Also in der letzten Stunde. Genau, in der letzten Stunde, da findet diese Separation
statt und dann dreht sich dann das Crewmodul einmal um um die eigene Achse.
Das Crewmodul hat nochmal ein eigenes Lageregelungstriebwerkssystem eingebaut
und das dreht sich dann quasi um, um mit dem Hitzeschutzschild zuerst einzutreten.
Und dann findet halt der Wiedereintritt von dem Crewmodul statt und das Servicemodul,
das fliegt dann halt nebenan, macht seinen Wiedereintritt und verglüht dann
irgendwie in der Atmosphäre und ein paar Teile bleiben dann über und die landen dann im Pazifik.
Das Kuhmodul hat jetzt so eine Skipping-Trajektorie, da sind die geflogen.
Man kann ja zum Beispiel auch direkt eintreten, indem man quasi eine direkte
Flugbahn hat, da hat man sehr hohe Wärmelast.
Die sind dann quasi reingekommen, haben dann nochmal hochgezogen und sind dann
nochmal wieder eingetreten.
Also quasi haben die vom Höhenprofil, es ging erst steil runter,
dann ging es wieder ein bisschen hoch und dann ging es wieder steil runter.
Kann man das denn steuern?
Über den Anstellwinkel von der Kapsel. Durch dieses Lage-Regelungssystem sind
wir in der Lage, das Raumschluss zu drehen und anzustellen.
Und dann über die Aerodynamik kann man das dann so einstellen,
dass man verschiedene Trajektorien in der Atmosphäre fliegen kann.
Also ist das so ein bisschen, als wenn man einen flachen Stein über Wasser...
Ungefähr, daher kommt das, glaube ich, Skippring-Trajektorie.
Genau, also man trifft sozusagen auf, aber stellt einfach durch die Schräglage fest,
dass man so viel Auftrieb wieder erhält, dass man wieder hochkommt und dadurch
ist dann insgesamt die Bremswirkung größer als würde man einfach straight sofort
eintauchen bzw. man nicht dieselben Temperaturen.
Ja und auch vor allen Dingen, so ich das verstanden habe, dass das halt ein
Design, was die Verzögerung, also die mechanischen Lasten ein bisschen reduziert,
was natürlich gut ist für die Astronauten.
Aber anscheinend ist es halt schon eh ein ziemlich anspruchsvoller Wiedereintritt
für die Astronauten von so einer hohen Geschwindigkeit.
Und so kann man das ein bisschen verteilen sozusagen die Wärmelast und auch
die mechanischen Lasten.
Dass man dann nicht so eine hohe Bremskraft hat oder eine Bremswirkung und das
natürlich dann auch mehrere Gs und die Astronauten dann nicht unbedingt in der
Höhe, dann lieber zweimal weniger als einmal richtig.
Wie lange kriegt man noch Daten von dem Service-Modul, bis es komplett verglüht ist?
Sobald es getrennt ist, ist es weg, weil wir keine Datenverbindung mehr haben
zum Kronmodul. Ach so und das Kronmodul funkt?
Genau, das Kronmodul funkt, wir funken nicht. Wir haben mal Datenverbindungen
natürlich zum Kronmodul, aber sobald diese Nabel- schnur getrennt ist, ist Feierabend.
Schade. Das ist eigentlich sehr schade, weil ich meine, gut der Wiedereintritt,
der ist halt was er ist, aber was wir hatten, wir hatten ja auf den,
daher kamen auch die ganzen tollen Bilder während der Atemmission,
wir hatten ja Kameras auf diesen Solarpaneel, an den Enden von den Solarpaneeln.
Man hat dem Projekter liebevoll Selfie-Sticks so gesagt, weil man die wirklich
so benutzt worden hat. Man hatte wirklich das Gefühl, die Leute vom Public Affairs
Office von der NASA, also von den Kommunikationsleuten.
Die haben das wirklich rumgefahren, um sich das Raumschiff von allen Seiten
anzugucken, dann halt damit auch die Fotos zu schießen von Mond, Erde und so weiter.
Und das ist eine Wi-Fi-Verbindung und die kann eigentlich theoretisch sogar
ein bisschen länger funken, also bis halt das Grundmodul, der Router sozusagen.
Wirklich Wi-Fi jetzt? Also normales WLAN tatsächlich? Normales WLAN.
Ernsthaft? Ja, aber da sind ja GoPros.
Ah, wirklich?
Ja, im Core sind das GoPros.
Also im Core sind das GoPros, die da auf den Solarpanelen sitzen.
Da wurde der Chip und die Kamera. Und dann wurde da ein Gehäuse drum gebaut,
was dann halt Raumfahrt qualifiziert wurde und so weiter.
Und da gibt es ein WLAN-System für die Kameras.
Ich glaube im Prinzip könnte das sogar funktionieren, weil dann die Kameras, die kriegen noch Strom.
Eigentlich oder haben Materie oder sowas und die könnten dann eigentlich noch
ein bisschen die Trennung sich angucken, ging aber diesmal nicht.
Aus irgendwelchen technischen Gründen, die mir nicht bekannt sind.
Ja genau, dann ist halt, die Bilder waren natürlich spektakulär vom Anflug auf
die Erde. Also man hat natürlich die größte Beschleunigung von dem Raumschiff,
wenn es dann in den Gravity Well von der Erde geht.
Und man sieht halt wirklich, dann kommt man da an, man läuft ins Kontrollzentrum,
die Erde ist noch so klein klein und am Ende wird die immer größer.
Man kann es wirklich auf dem Bildschirm dann größer werden sehen,
wenn es dann zu der Trennung kommt. So ein ziemlich beeindruckender Moment. Und dann hatten wir,
den Stream von der Kamera aus dem True-Modul, wo man quasi mit der Kamera aus
dem Fenster geguckt hat und man hat dann gesehen, okay, jetzt ist Eintritt,
weil das Plasma gerade am Fenster vorbeifliegt.
Und dann war ja auch Funkstelle, da gibt es ja diese Blackout-Windows,
wenn das Plasma eine gewisse Stärke hat, wo man nicht mehr durchfunkt.
Da geht einfach nichts mehr durch, ne?
Ja, man kann nicht mehr durchfunkten, es ist halt dann elektrisch geladene Strömung um das Raumschiff rum.
Und dann, nach dem ersten Eintrittsteil, wenn dieses Skipping beginnt, dann hat man wieder...
Dann hat man wieder Kontakt und dann hat man auch toll gesehen,
schon okay, ich fliege halt mit einer riesigen Geschwindigkeit über die Erde,
man saut die Erde und dann hat man das halt, hat man wieder ein Blackout gehabt
und dann sah man schon, okay, jetzt sind wir ja wirklich nah dran.
Und dann kamen auch schon die Bilder vom Recovery Ship.
Man hat dann da die Fallschirme gesehen, die rausgeflogen sind und wir waren
natürlich mega happy zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo das Service Modul weg war,
also als Europäer, unser Job war es done, well done.
Aber man will ja auch, dass die Mission als Pflicht hier funktioniert.
Ja genau, für mich wäre die Mission kein Erfolg gewesen, wenn da was am Q-Modul passiert wäre.
Obwohl wir nur in Anführungsstrichen das Service-Modul liefern,
ist man da integraler Teil des Oraleprogramms und auch Artemis als ESA-Mitarbeiterin,
auch als Airbus-Mitarbeiterin.
Das würde ja auch niemand anders sagen. Also würde keiner sagen,
ich bin nur für das Service-Modul zuständig und für das Rest ist mir egal.
Das wird dir hier auf dem Flur keiner sagen und das wird dir auch bei den Kollegen
in Bremen keiner sagen. Die sind alle Teil vom Artemis-Programm.
Und dementsprechend, als die Fallschirme rausgingen, du weißt halt,
okay, da kann noch mal was daneben gehen. Das ist ein zweistufiges Fallschirmsystem.
Kann mal was passieren. Und als die draußen waren, alle happy,
dann kam auch der NASA-Chef rein, hat man noch eine Ansprache gemacht.
Der Bill Nelson kam rein.
Das war dann ganz schön. Da hatten wir einen kleinen Umtrunk bei NASA auf dem Gelände.
Die Mission ging im Endeffekt nochmal zwei Stunden weiter, weil die haben die
Kapsel nochmal zwei Stunden lang wassern lassen.
Auch aus Testzwecken, normalerweise machst du das nicht, holst du das schnell
wie möglich rein, aber die mussten halt zeigen, okay wir können zwei Stunden
wassern, unsere Systeme bleiben halt aktiv und können die Astronauten am Leben
erhalten, nochmal zwei Stunden danach.
Da sind glaube ich noch so Sicherheitsballons aufgeblasen worden.
Ja genau, die sind halt zum Floating Devices.
Zum Schluss blicken wir vielleicht mal kurz noch auf, was jetzt noch so ansteht.
Artemis 2 und 3 haben wir jetzt schon ein paar Mal erwähnt.
Das sind dann sozusagen die entscheidenden Missionen. Was ändert sich jetzt bei Artemis 2?
Und klar, bei 3 sind natürlich dann die Astronauten mit dabei. Was ändert sich dann?
Bei Artemis 2 haben wir noch immer den gleichen Launcher. Wir haben bei Artemis
2 dann eine Crew an Bord, eine amerikanische Crew.
Im Service-Modul gab es...
Das heißt, Artemis 2 ist im Prinzip nochmal das gleiche wie Artemis 1, was den Flug betrifft?
Nein, nein, der Flug ist komplett anders. Der Flug ist ganz einfach.
Es gibt einen Free Return, heißt das.
Das heißt, man, im Endeffekt fliegt man auf einer Bahn, also man macht diese
Translunar Injection, also diesen Einschuss auf die Mondumlaufbahn, aber nichts weiter.
Man fliegt dann nur am Mond vorbei und fliegt dann direkt zurück,
ohne irgendwelche Manöver am Mond selber durchzuführen.
Es gibt dann quasi nachher nur noch Lageregelung. Warum?
Also ich meine, wenn man das vorher schon so geübt hat, warum macht man es dann anders?
Ja, man will halt natürlich die Mission zum einen nicht zu lang machen,
weil man erst einmal die Astronauten, also Risiko ist eine Risikoabwägung,
glaube ich, von der Missionsdesign, dass man sagt, okay, wir fliegen jetzt in
eine bemannte Mission, damit die Crew sich ans Raumschiff gewöhnen.
Jetzt wird das Raumschiff an die Crew gewöhnt.
Hall.
9000.
Also die Mission wird dann so wie folgt aussehen, wir werden dann wirklich auch
einen Tag im Erdorbit erstmal sein und da werden die Lebenserhaltungssysteme getestet.
Macht ja auch Sinn, dass man nicht sich direkt jetzt wie bei Artemis 1 auf Richtung
Mond begibt und nach drei Stunden fällt einem auf, oh wir haben keine Luft mehr.
Das wäre natürlich schlecht und deswegen macht man erst einen Tag,
wo dann das ausgetestet werden kann und man macht eine Runde VU und einen Docking-Test im Erdorbit.
Und es geht ja darum, dass man
bei Artemis 3 mit dieser Mondlandefähre im Mondorbit, sage ich mal, dockt.
Das muss man am besten noch mal testen vorher. Und das machen wir dann auch
noch im Mondorbit. Und dann, sehr interessant auch für mein System,
dann wird dieser Mondeinschuss, nicht mit der Oberstufe gemacht,
weil die ist dann ja schon längst weg, die wird dann mit dem Orion gemacht.
Und das ist dann vielleicht auch ein Grund, warum man nachher dann keinen,
keinen, nicht mehr ausreichenden Treibstoff hat, um irgendwelchen Mondeinschuss
zu machen, so wie wir es jetzt gemacht haben.
Haben. Also generell eine Abwägung, was will ich in der Mission machen,
was sind meine Capabilities vom Raumschiff und dann findet halt ein relativ
großer Bören von dem Haupttriebwerkstatt um Richtung Mond zu fliegen.
Und dann kommt man nach, glaube ich, neun Tagen wieder zurück,
landet dann die Astronauten sicher und hat dann das Raumschiff getestet mit den Astronauten.
Das heißt, für das Service-Modul liegt dann der Fokus in der zweiten Mission
weniger auf den Antrieb.
Er ist natürlich auch erforderlich, aber es gibt jetzt wie gesagt nicht diese
Brems- und Wiederbeschleunigungsmanöver, aber mehr auf die Versorgung des Moduls etc.
Und gerade auch im Crew-Modul, was so ein Onboard-Computer-Jugend-Interface ist. Wahrscheinlich.
Toilettensysteme, ich weiß nicht, was man da noch testen muss mit dem Astronauten.
Also einfach so die Sachen, die halt mit dem Interface zwischen Astronauten
und Raumschiff zusammenhängen.
Ich sage mal voraus, dass die Nervosität beim zweiten Start noch größer sein wird als beim ersten.
Ja, das denke ich auch, weil es ist ja nochmal eine ganz andere Verantwortung.
Das Gute ist, dass wir jetzt wissen, wie gut unser System funktionieren kann.
Und wir haben ja auf der gleichen Weise das Service-Modul gebaut und getestet, wie beim ersten Mal.
Sogar noch besser, weil Lessons Learned.
Und deswegen glaube ich, wenn wir das Modul abgeliefert haben,
sind wir da genauso gut in Shape wie bei Atmos 1.
Das gibt ein bisschen Ruhe auf der anderen Seite, wenn die ersten Mal die Astronauten
drauf sitzen, dann will man natürlich nicht, dass man noch eine Anomalie hat,
die ja immer auftreten kann.
Und dann weiß ich auch nicht, ob ich da unbedingt, also das ist natürlich eine Sache da,
also das wäre natürlich ziemlich heftig, wenn man so eine Apollo 13 Situation
hat und man sitzt da im Team,
was die Anomalie dann irgendwie aufzulösen hat, das wäre natürlich schon,
das ist eine Situation, die keiner haben möchte und die wahrscheinlich auch
nicht auftreten wird, aber man weiß es nie.
Letzter Ausblick dann vielleicht auch noch mal auf Artemis 3.
Okay.
So ganz zum Schluss. Das wird ja dann so ein bisschen die Krönung,
die vorläufige Krönung, soll ja noch weitere Missionen geben,
aber das ist ja jetzt erstmal das mittelfristige Ziel.
Wie wird es dann laufen mit dem Lander?
Wir haben ja jetzt quasi eine Mission geflogen, um in den Mond Orb zu kommen.
Von der Oralenseite her wird das relativ ähnlich laufen.
Der Lander, das ist so eine, im Endeffekt diese SpaceX-Oberstufe, die die jetzt beim...
Das Spaceship meintest du jetzt?
Ja, das Spaceship, ja. Was in Bocotico da auf dem Pad grad steht.
Was ja auch jetzt, also was gerade wichtig ist, ist, dass das ist eigentlich
mal eine Sache für mich, da ich ja auch nicht unbedingt da in dem Programm so
involviert bin. Das ist nochmal ein viertes Programm, was bei der NASA läuft,
um Landing System. Da kriegen wir relativ wenig damit.
Muss ich wirklich sagen, was in den Nachrichten steht, das verfolgen wir natürlich.
Die müssen halt erstmal die Rakete starten, also dieses Spaceship starten und
dann das Juven Landing System dementsprechend bauen, in den Mondorbit kriegen.
Also im Endeffekt geht es darum, die müssen mehrere Speichel bauen.
Weil die ja Betankungen im Erdorbit machen müssen, dann müssen sie mit dem Spaceship
zum Mondorbit fahren, dann muss das wieder im Mondorbit betankt werden,
damit sie dann auf die Mondoberfläche landen können und wieder hochkommen können.
Das ist quasi eine Raumfahrtinfrastruktur für nötig, die gibt es ja heutzutage
noch nicht. Und das Ganze soll in drei Jahren im Endeffekt stattfinden.
SpaceX ist schnell, schneller als eine vergleichbare Firma, aber selbst bei
Crew Dragon, Also quasi dem Versorgungsschiff für die Raumstation gab es ja
50 Prozent Projektverzug.
Das ist nicht unbedingt gesagt, dass es nur weil SpaceX ist,
dass es dann innerhalb des vorgesehenen Planchefes ist. Aber müssen wir mal sehen.
Gut, das ist halt für mich der kritische Punkt, weil da gibt es noch nichts.
Aber wir von Orion wissen, okay, wir können, gerade wenn wir bei Atomos 2 geflogen
sind, wir können dann mit Astronauten zum Mond orbit.
Aber vom Ablauf her ist es dann im Prinzip wieder wie die erste Mission?
Ja, genau, es ist dann eher so wie die erste Mission, dass Orion auch in Mondorbit
muss, wo sich dann dieses Human Landing System befindet von SpaceX.
Das heißt, wir werden dann docken mit diesem HLS Human Landing System.
Das muss man sich so vorstellen, wir sind der Delfin und das HLS ist der Wal,
so von der großen Ordnung.
Also wir sind halt ein kleines System, was dann dieses große Human Landing System,
was die Oberschrift vom Spaceship ist und damit fliegen dann die Astronauten
runter auf den Mond und fliegen dann wieder zurück,
docken mit Orion, steigen um und fliegen damit dann zurück zur Erde.
Und warum müssen wir das machen? Weil SpaceX kann mit Dragon und Crew Dragon
aus dem Leo zurückkommen.
Also aus dem Low Earth Orbit zurückkommen.
SpaceX legt Spaceship aus, um aus dem Low Earth Orbit wieder zurückzukommen.
Mit den Hitzeschutzkacheln, die da angebaut werden und so weiter.
Aber es ist halt noch nicht nachgewiesen, dass sie überhaupt einen Wiedereintritt
mit den Motgeschwindigkeiten machen können. was halt wesentlich komplexer ist.
Und das ist halt momentan, das Orion mit dem erfolgreichen Flug,
das einzige qualifizierte Raumschiff, was einen Return, einen Wiedereintritt vom Mond machen kann.
Deswegen brauchen wir das, um die Astronauten zurückzukriegen vom Mond-Orbit.
Vielleicht ändert sich das in der Zukunft, man weiß es nicht in langfristig.
Also wenn da gewisse Capabilities entstehen bei SpaceX, wo das passiert,
aber ich sehe das halt momentan auch nicht kurzfristig eintreten einfach.
Man sagt immer, SpaceX würde das alles übernehmen, aber es gibt durchaus auch
technische Hürden, die da sind, das könnte man sicher nicht mehr kommen.
Aber die Physik gilt auch für viele, die es machen. Das ist so.
Gut Tobias, ich sage vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Gerne. Hier zu eurem spannenden
Projekt und dem auch wirklich sehr gut laufenden Projekt und gut laufenden Kooperationen.
Ich hoffe, das wird auch weiterhin so laufen.
Insofern alles Gute dafür. Ja und vielen Dank dafür und ich bedanke mich auch.
Fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Bald geht es wieder weiter. Ich sage tschüss, bis bald.